jean alert denim loose all over everyone
pull doors up we failed to mention we
have a few live podcasts coming up these
are live versions of your mom's house
they're really fun totally different
energy than a studio show and we have we
have actually four on the books but
three of them are on sale now the first
one coming up in Irvine at the Irvine
improv is what they sperm vine July 9th
July 9th then we do breast palm beach
the west palm improv in Florida and that
is August 23rd August 23rd and then we
are back in Irvine in October that's
also on sale and then we have one in
December that we can't announce yet but
all of those you can go if you go to my
site Tom Segura comm you click on the
tour page you will see all at the very
bottom the live podcast dates so October
8th will during the academic okay there
you go check it out come see the podcast
live
[Music]
big time [ __ ] coming up Jeannie yeah
major can I go ahead and announce it oh
you should I mean I did it during the
episode because it's such big news but
I'm proud to announce finally my special
is taping in Seattle June 24th
at the Showbox theater tickets are
available at Thousand ranch dot-com
there are two shows a 7 and a 9:30
taping I would love to pack that house
full of mommies why not so come see me
there and then ramping up to it I just
have two weeks left I'm going to Denver
Comedy Works June 1st through 3rd a
man-friend disco at the punchline June
16th and 17th and then one last call
show before I tape June 22nd here at
flappers comedy club in Burbank in the
yoohoo room again all links on thousand
ranch calm shouldn't big time price so
excite proud of you girl I gotta catch
up to you you've got like I just started
you because a guy just folded you got
like two side specials and six babies
and marriages a lot of kids dance calm
for me let's see next time at the Rialto
Theatre in Tucson then the Grand Theatre
in Reno and then I'm doing Pechanga in
Temecula how I then hit the dirty south
from in Virginia I'm in North Carolina
South Carolina in July and then I go to
Montreal Hampton Beach Wilmington
Baltimore also in July and then I round
things out in Australia mom Australia
all at Tom Segura calm click on the tour
page it's all there I have June 5th I'll
be announcing my fall date so there's a
bunch of cities coming up but I haven't
been able to say and I will announce
those on June 5th thank you so much go
to Tom Segar com
hey guys don't forget to go to your
mom's house podcast.com please do your
amazon shopping through our amazon
banner it gives a little kick back to
the show helps support the show and we
have a amazon banner for the US we have
an Amazon Canada banner and we have a UK
banner so anybody listening in those
three countries can just do the regular
shopping you would do and you go and and
you support the show just by buying what
you would normally buy also there's a
bunch of new stuff in our store if you
go to Tom Segura com click on the store
take you to our merch method store we
have a bunch of new shirts we've
restocked stuff I've signed completely
normal and mostly stories google has a
DVD closely stories audio vinyls coming
out for both next month so I keep
getting asked about vinyl both will be
available in vinyl next month and like I
said the glassing poster the glass and
shirt all those things are now in the
store you can please go to Tom Segura
com click on the store and I think
that's it Jean that's wonderful this
episode of your mom's house is brought
to you by sattva the online leading
mattress company
it's a bachelor Magina I sleep on we
just woke up on it and we've loved that
we've slept on it for years now it is
environmentally friendly it is super
comfortable and they don't have a retail
store which means they pass on the
savings to you the consumer there's no
rent
there's no Commission's there's no
electric bill they are able to sell that
for a very reasonable price and I'm
telling you there's nothing like
investing in your sleep
how did for sure it is so worth and
doing that and it's not that a huge of a
monetary investment with satva because
you're getting a luxury product for a
fraction of the cost and the customer
service is outstanding out of this world
out of this world 24/7 you can chat talk
on the phone we had
people following up in clacey order
following up when they made the delivery
they offer also offer mattress takeaway
service not highly recommend it's a
nominal fee unless you want to be that
guy that has a mattress in his yard and
if you think that people won't talk
about you let me tell you some people
talk about you not favorably yeah
unfavorably about being the guy with a
mattress in his yard no don't be that
guy go to sattva mattress si a TV a
mattress comm if you want a memory foam
mattress their company loom and leaf LOM
and leaf has online memory foam mattress
absolutely incredible our own blue band
sleeps on it thank you
sattva your mom's house is supported in
part by barkbox workbooks workbooks a
monthly package of four to six natural
treats and super fun toys curated around
the surprise theme we got the Bart Bart
box as you know we have two little fur
babies who we just adore more than life
and it was wonderful I had so many great
treats that bitsy a temp she's already
too fat for her her size but she gobbled
up all those wonderful treats and the
toys are great too because you know
we've got a kid we forget to buy toys
for the dog sometimes I guess he likes
that little little blue squeaky so we
care here because we get she was broke
yeah yeah and the newspaper they gave us
like a fake newspaper crinkling thing
make the dogs just love that every month
Burt bucks picks the best all-natural
treats made in the USA or Canada an
innovative toys to match dogs unique
needs including allergies and heavy chew
or preferences well we got a heavy cheer
if your dog doesn't like something in
the Box bark box we'll send you
something to love for free bark box is a
great way to try a variety of treats and
toys from local and small businesses
that you may not otherwise be able to
find that's true I noticed that that
those toys were special not the crap
that you're finding no
down to the the Megastore no die quality
yeah it was real they're really cool for
a free extra premium toy added to your
to your bark box every month visit bark
box.com slash mom's house when you
subscribe to a 6 or 12 month plan then
select yes please when asked have a
playful pup again that URL is bark box
calm slash mom's house what a nice way
to spoil your fur babies in your life I
love it especially because we're going
to automate this now and then they get a
nice little treat
and finally this episode is brought to
you by stamps comm I got to tell you I'm
done wasting my time on things that
waste my time get your life and I'm not
going to the post office again as long
as I live and the reason the wind I can
be thankful to for that stamps calm I
used to do that I used to load up the
car with packages and letters and drive
out to the post office park and then
which line and where how do I and then
you wait and smell people and just an
hour would go by and just I got done all
this from my own house yes yeah
now stamps calm brings you all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer stamps comm makes
it easy to send you a digital scale
automatically calculate exact post egde
Sam calm will even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs
no need to lease an expensive postage
meter we use stamps calm because it
saves us time and because it saves us
money and right now you too can enjoy
the stamps services with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps calm click
on the microphone on the top of the
homepage and type in mom that stamps
enter the code word mom stamps.com never
go to the post office again mob no we're
very happy to bring to you this episode
we have our good friend the the pod
father if you were oh my god did you
just come up with that now I've heard
that before I was really good yeah the
pod father Wow our buddy Joe Rogan and I
didn't mention during our date rundown
but he is doing a massive tour where
he's adding five thousand seat venues
Nana's isn't a banana isn't incredible
and like I'm proud of I sound funny
because he's always been proud but I
mean I'm proud of him because if seen
him just just go go Todd's rocket ship
you know bananas it's amazing how much
he's done and we talk about a little bit
in this episode how normal he is yeah
it's special I mean that's pretty rare
but look if you want to see him if
you're a fan and you're just finding out
he's doing this tour I'm telling you you
got to hop on hop on it now
yes he's uh he's been telling you to
keep selling these things out there like
months in advance and they're already
gone it's crazy so go to Joe Rogan
dotnet slash tour and see if he's coming
to a city near you and get your tickets
immediately because they won't be around
but many thanks to Joe for coming and
help you guys enjoy this episode it's a
fine line thank you for gracing us with
your presence today my pleasure
apparently it's been a while it has been
do ii guess we've had in three years
whoa yeah already stop doing guest a
long time ago but then now we have this
setup we're like we should bring guests
back yeah why not why not pocket yeah
it's fine view we told you we had the
water so many here last week yeah some
people thought it was a joke
and they wrote in like hey I turned it
off I thought that bit was going kind of
long yeah a bit well because we play
boring cliffs on the show sometimes yeah
people are like that was a long as
boring Club yeah that's awell site yeah
when there's many laughs we'll be like
what
were down a little bit they play some
boring and there's a long but got a
peach in valleys yeah what were their
expectations that's really long
yeah so we had a bunch of people that
some people were I would say most people
were fascinated I was [ __ ] fatty so
tight I had no idea until I walked in
here that that was a real thing yeah and
he works at patina which is a restaurant
downtown which he'd been there but he
created a water menu there yeah so when
people go come on and you're like yeah
can I have you know you ordered and he's
like to drink and you go I'll just have
water he'll be like I'll be right back
and then it's a water menu so you get to
do it basically does what we were
telling you but you know like a
beautiful presentation and people start
if I went out to a restaurant out of
water menu I it depends on how high amp
yeah I was really hard you like what's
going on yeah but if I was sober like
Park you I'm leaving but if you're
really high you might be like bringing
one of everything let me try all this to
try your water man yeah are we have an
opening clip before we just before we
get into our regulars this is how we
open our show we'll play our clip and
then we'll get into it here we go around
June the 21st when a Skype when
tarantulas skyping with me a friend
spider said hey you toran so something's
going on with Matthew McConaughey's
penis moment happening because all of my
men's penises were being attacked homes
Randy don't bring anyone love into this
no bother the phone is bad well welcome
welcome to your mom's house
with Sakura
[Music]
courses
how can you doubt feeling oh I know
what's this brother
do you mean I can what is she talking
about rational yeah without a deal there
yeah nothing that's that one force
Whitaker I go on right i yeah yeah and
there's also there's something about
crazy that does something to your you
know the way you see eyes and you could
tell you can't talking to her person
you'd be like even if she didn't say
crazy penis [ __ ] you be like sums up
with her
oh yeah well it's the the gays that
doesn't break that's right
yeah there's no blanking yeah a real
indicator of insanity of those Elijah
there was a very serious malware in the
computer system at Church of Galen cause
all the manager to Gail to cause
something all sorts of penis afflictions
very painful Church of Gail I think
that's her own church Church of Gayle oh
I think why don't she think it has to do
with Matthew McConaughey I don't know
but she goes on deal with the penis is
lasted for at least a good week in that
gym like from June 21st June 28th a
we're just having this ordeal with
penises because of Jesuit trigger
programming on the Church of Gayle
computers they spent a lot of time in
sick bay
there's matters you have to go ahead of
now at that point yeah what it was right
man vagina Matthews penis went inward
I think it's laying that she thinks that
the Jesuits are targeting her here there
should be Jesuits are very affable
they're fun yeah early education college
chant they like to drink they like to
party they're not really into the stuff
you know what's interesting about her if
you didn't know any better like if you
spoke a different language and you
listen to her talk be like well she
seems totally rational
yeah she's sitting there calmly she's
not she's moving too much and maybe
she's an expert in like ancient
civilization is how a lot of cons happen
I'm assuming you know like I was
watching that Bernie Madoff movie the
new one really good with DeNiro and
Michelle Pfeiffer yes I which is called
Wizard of lies
they were just talking about how like
his greatest skill was just people
manipulating and he had this crazy thing
where he was as the craziest part he was
already successful he was really
well-off he's a multi-millionaire and
he's still you know designed this Ponzi
scheme to extract so much more out of
people and they said you know because
his reputation was such and he was just
knew how to talk to each other just
handing over money man he was just in it
too far people over like you're fun no I
was screwing people a little bit yes how
I'm real sorry that super addicted to
the cash yeah there's a great interview
with him on radio lab and it's really
interesting because they have to
interview them from jail and so when you
call someone in jail you can only talk
to them for 15 minutes huh and then you
have to wait off the phone for 15
minutes for them to come back on then
fifteen minutes again so they're
interviewing this guy these 15 minute
shocks and it just cuts off at 15
minutes and he has to wait terrible and
eight but he's describing you know this
waiting and then as time went on he
talks to Madoff more and more he gets
more and more comfortable but the crazy
thing about him is the complete total
lack of empathy none is no empathy
towards the people he [ __ ] over people
that killed themselves like there was a
bunch of people that just one guy which
is really fascinating he was worth nine
billion dollars and Bernie was telling
him that he had to give seven of it back
he called the guy up because look the
jig is up
everybody knows and apparently he he
thinks or at least his rationale was
that all these people like the big high
roller guys they knew that they were
ripping people off they knew that there
was no way you could always make money
that there was always going to be
fluctuation but like even in like the
way they described it I don't really
necessarily understand finances that
much but the way they were describing it
is that in like every single move they
made this one guy wanted to make money
every single like there was never you
can he couldn't ever show any losses at
all this guy would freak out and you
have like again seven billion dollars in
the mix that's insane yeah yeah he he
said in an interview that when they were
like asking him about you know you
destroyed all these people lives he was
like what about their culpability and
all this and he's like well you know I
mean they have some responsibility and
they're like you stole from them he's
like yeah but they [ __ ] gave me the
money you know yeah this thing was like
these people these people they're not
starving that's what it said yeah we're
not talking about people in Africa you
know when I was talking about starving
villagers we're just talking about
people his own son killed himself really
yep is one of them killed himself genius
guy killed himself that we're talking
about the nine billion dollar guy he
killed himself because you want they
wanted him to give back seven players
yelling with you [ __ ] that yeah that's a
lot of people's relationship with money
there was a kid we might not Jones on my
ground oh really
yeah I might just took too many drugs
but there was a a New York Knick I
forget his name and they were
interviewing him about you know these
NBA contracts are bananas oh it's fully
guaranteed it's one of the league's has
fully guaranteed money so now like the
NFL where it's like you have this less
guaranteed the rest of that you're not
getting that [ __ ]
so NBA whatever you know there's salary
caps and he played out one of the
contracts and I we want to keep you but
we can't give you like top-end money so
you're going to get nine million for
next year and then his first interview
with the press he was like I mean you
know it's going to be tough but I'll see
what I know make it happen if you're
gonna be tough but survive on that he
was like pretty much I mean I'm a family
man there's like just perspective man
you're crazy yeah well yeah cuz if he's
going out I mean you know I follow all
these kids on Instagram like Cameron
Dallas you know who that is no he's like
Bush the Millennial hot [ __ ] he's like
this hot eighteen year old boy and he
and his friends they fit into this but
you're getting a great size listen they
don't have talent they're just like cute
boys on Instagram and they do these meet
and greets where they meet like gaggles
just auditoriums theaters full of like
tween pre-adolescent girls and their
parents and they hug them and take like
chaste pictures and millionaires
millionaire he's on a dolce gabbana I
know
skill set none but not yeah just they
follow them on Instagram and I look at
you team boys yeah and then yes hey to
meet the people it is fascinating so
there's a there's a Netflix show called
chasing cameras yeah and I'm obsessed
now the thing is that they they're
spending their money like crazy because
I followed them all on Instagram and
every week it's like here's my new
Ferrari here's the new Lamborghini I'm
leasing here's the new house I'm renting
and you're like you're not even buying I
should buy that house too yeah an equity
yeah there's r18 yes but they're also
like I think they don't realize that
that window of cute girls that were
being cute in the girls room like you is
very limited yeah everybody sells out
about Kim Kardashian yeah I guess so
right but they suck they keep growing
new ones you know what I'm saying it's
like oh yeah like in the different
strokes and they added like the red
haired kid to make the show appealing
again going about the chase or the
Kardashian Kardashian
oh they keep the so now Kylie's being
groomed alright I think that's what
keeps it going it does I think it's all
about him really yeah it's kim min-ji
even though they all about her is a real
mother mother a Chris Kennedy's like the
matriarch of the did you guys cover her
fake ass nothing big ass photos from
Mexico no I think I saw some of the all
here's the deal they always hire their
own paparazzi and the paparazzi pretends
to just casually catch them taking
pictures but in Mexico there was real
paparazzi waiting along with their fake
paparazzi so they're fake paparazzi
takes the photos and then they edit them
they smooth out all the cellulite and
all the foliage I didn't have it I mean
yeah I mean it's normal human part of
you especially a big fat outside it's
made of fat but it's it's a fake fat ass
and it's super obvious in the new
pictures look at me later
get your life cut that's a real one like
look at the ones on the left like where
in life would you have that's a tumor
right that's a full diaper yeah diaper
hey Charlie is yeah legs are so scrawny
and then she has this giant enormous
butt so what they would do with
Photoshop will stretch out the side to
meet the ass so it doesn't look so
[ __ ] through this like that
that one doctored yeah yeah doctored
ones make it look less preposterous
rather the real one it just looks like
gen malaria rose like I did you just up
like that what the [ __ ] is that what is
that you doing your ISO rate rose Nathan
so crazy but it's it's so not that
someone I think it wants to do that to
their body like nothing something in
there I don't know what it is but
there's no way in nature you would have
those skinny ass legs like that there
are total unathletic legs that I feel as
if someone it doesn't work like her
sister yeah exactly right there's no
muscle I don't know nothing I mean I
mean she maybe works out a little bit we
were scrawny arms yeah she's not an
athletic person right you have an ass
like that you should be able to jump
over the moon right right that's someone
who can do hurdles but she's kind of
good so do you think wait but she looks
good everywhere else these are all
Photoshop let me main that's hard to
clean it's hard to say yeah this time
everything's fake and when you say she
looks good it's like yeah she's not fat
right but but that's it everything else
is just all sorted today yeah that's a
Vegas [ __ ] yeah well I mean that's her
whole thing she's known perhaps like
Jennifer Lopez has a legit latina ass
great like that's her real ass yeah her
legs match that ass right like take a
picture you'll go get yeah Jennifer
Lopez's ass she's got those big thick
mommy sighs yeah yeah yeah that's all
there that's real you know you look at
that you go oh baby yes that's real
that's a real big juicy ass God an egg
girl yeah see how her thighs are so
thick the yeah the ass yeah that's all
in order that makes sense yeah hundred
percent that's what it's supposed to
look like she's a dancer Oh classy hi
mom yeah yeah you're right that's
dancing all [ __ ] day Lorelei's a week
yes that's an athlete ass
yeah that's a girl who can yeah you do
that's a girl who can bounce around and
move and you know I mean cue magic you
gotta watch Kim Kardashian dance on the
stage know those little spindly legs
carrying that diaper around yeah
just look like baby Dyson we see that
all day what I said it totally looks
like that's what an ass a big joonyoung
real ass is supposed to look like it's
not preposterous it's just outstanding
yeah yeah I didn't know she had a butt
implant to stress something though on
that my wedding one I would say that's a
that's a there's there's a photo there
that has the two of them side by side
her shirt over right there that's
Jennifer Lopez and Kim Kardashian the
one with the white right here here here
here okay so you the one on the left is
Jennifer Lopez it has a real ass on the
right is Kim Kardashian is it yeah well
my ass obsessed ompletely know you know
so much about this no I'm doing no shoes
no down the wormhole it's a very bizarre
thing it is a retraction to shapes is
very bizarre 2/3 like like fake tears
like we know they're fake that that
always astounds me like it's not that
they look like bigger breasts they look
like big fakers yeah they're two
different things you guys like it
some guy some guy would say some guys I
mean some guys meaning it's a ton of
guys but some guys make that distinction
like definitely not into that yeah see
but I mean you said this before that
you'd prefer hungry tits over big fakers
yeah any day I'm great hungry little
ones yeah we need to be fed yeah I would
rather give souffléd uh I was just pasta
to those hungry tits then yeah I don't
like big fakers man yeah there's
something weird about them for sure now
trick I will say a really good job of
fakes like you can there are some
magicians out there yeah that they
create amazing like they still look you
sort of those look good yeah but I still
prefer real ones I know I just like some
work I think so look I got no body
dysmorphia sense yeah because when do
you wear it look once you have a baby to
your tits get mushy
that's it that's just its nature so what
should i do should i host them up should
I have them reduce talked about first of
all yes it does [ __ ] yourself or no
women yes and our population is going to
die off
got a Mamba quiet Jesus but it's fine
but what you know you've got a surrender
it's also our life I know it's the
trade-off for making life now are these
real or the Lakers you seem excited for
the past on trainer and nutritionist
Ivor I'm very much into fitness I will
clean and a healthy body
so surprisingly a lot nutritional
benefits from Weston seaman some of it
can be read up to now needs well egami
yeah she's primitive demon contains over
250 don't know how Christmas minute
wisdom including human face calcium
chloride lunatic acid chlorine that's my
good boy yes
my name is Moshe oh well in sodium this
is B so I think wow lookin sharp measure
those your kid kids on YouTube talking
about income yeah we should all come
well what I like about this because
we've had other come eating clips on the
show is the science that this woman is
cut Toria but she's a fitness expert
which is kind of neat we don't often
have expert yeah what I mean no what am
i a fitness expert you can just say you
are yeah thanks like being out a little
bit yeah and a life coach anybody can
say that there's another kid on a sports
bra and you're like look [ __ ] fitness
I like those things a weird one
yeah anyone can sign up for that [ __ ] I
was watching Anthony Robbins Instagram
stories Tony Robbins and then he's in
Australia and he gets out to that uh
with it was a black IP song tonight's
gonna be a good night and he's out there
yours clapping big [ __ ] price yeah ma
fire he's like stomping around on a
chair but it's all like it's it's like
he's is energy is kind of for yes and
he's got yes he's a little too wide
around the waist which means eating a
little too good yes living it up a
little too much so yes we're all excited
we're gonna prosper here say I know it
makes him crazy and it says Adam and one
of the photos I saved the photo because
I was laughing so hard I saved it on my
phone because it said Savage is a
picture of him and he's dancing around
clapping and it just says Savage I'm
like settle the [ __ ] down buddy
yeah where is it he uh by the way that
life coach things look Savage I sort of
Instagram stories so why is that Savage
it's in with his hands in his pocket
this all is dad bod relax some sovereign
I agree I like Tony Robbins a lot but
the fake energy thing if I went to his
seminar and he made me [ __ ] stand up
and do jumping jacks every five minutes
I blow my brains out I don't like that
answer
giant human by a giant ism or whatever
does he actually yeah it has a pituitary
ality really it was like even the jaw
you know the facial features there's
like a very mild form of it and I liked
it oh yes I'm serious I nog probably
it's gotta be part of what his
confidence is every time and every time
he's probably meeting with the team
there's enough pushback on something
goes let me show you something about
rolling carpet it's like look at that
thing
slaps that they done and it interns like
he's got a point
hold up pizza dough yeah it looks like
one of those so Cinnabon you buy at the
grocery store sell right sure right
those are good
those are so good buddy doing good look
how thin you are they call that after
I've been working it better than Burt
still I think Burt went right back
by the way so that that whole may read
your comment so do you think I just
write down push iam incoming a bowl it's
a friends a friends like I'm not in a
relationship a friend did this for money
bread what a nice guy
well listen I would say honey I'll come
in the boat honestly the best ways I
suck it out that we get all just for
your sake no I don't feel like a lot of
guys feel that way Jim you watch that I
know this is important I'm not into
watching people you come and no it's
weird
outside of porn it's disgusting I think
in court by the way where's like eight
dudes in the glass as far less my
favorite album you like my book part
what was enough guy hey guys [ __ ] on
graffiti and it's like you can tell the
real savages important who are these
like ah and they like they keep it going
it's like no big deal
but you can also see in the fate that
you can read someone so yeah when
they're like when you see that yeah and
they're like for the flincher of slinky
a little bacon thoose yeah yeah yeah I
mean gnarly but you got to thank the
ones that are really into it like no
they're not I mean you've got to be so
[ __ ] damage to be like I love eight
in a guy's 10 guys could you Oh mommy to
you and I did yeah she's gonna flip the
camera have 180 most mellow rather
bleach no no don't even more benefits to
drinking senior for women because it
only do you learn to depressant because
it contains mullet okay I can see the
audience reception vitamist alright oh
no I just got the chills for real no J's
it
Joan is he a dripping nasty yeah
surprisingly no it's not surprising
beautiful if everybody is a guy what
they're writing I produce some of my own
streaming videos watch give me a call if
you ever need some straight from the
source job I hope you at least give the
donor a hand job you selfish [ __ ] I have
lots of see when I could unload on those
big breasts Jesus why not disable the
comment I know she said yes rockin would
you date her knowing she's drunk to
drink so many come shots yeah of course
yeah cares I just have a little bit
about that yeah I know about that I
dated a girl once and she told me that
when guys drink fruit juice especially
pineapple juice oh yeah it makes your
[ __ ] taste better and I was like how many
dicks do you have to suck for you figure
that yeah like that no it's not lying to
it's Paris is not good okay let's try
roast beef the idea that you you've
figured that out to trial and error like
there's something really delicious about
your come today well different what
didn't I have look all over my diet to
do an autopsy of it to drank some water
and pineapple watch I get some water
from hungry that helps did you one thing
I don't think you got to see throughout
there was a four-month build-up
basically to the weigh-ins the Berta who
is fat weigh-ins where we were Bert
Kreischer and I came on I did see a
little bit of it on Instagram and on
Twitter with the hashtag bird is fat
I saw some of that did you see how I
mean like we had I want to show you this
this is like people would call in or
like send in videos saying bird is fat
in different languages is just amazing
why is the price is so fat bobert our
Cordova looks at the best guy that is 50
little rock good Crawshaw you are a fat
ton laugh at a constant Tom Segura might
and then this was my favorite then this
was amazing people that listen to the
podcast
teach English as a Second Language would
use the whole battle to teach English
abroad in different countries oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god just freak you guys out and
see how popular this is I love it
yeah when when I mean there was I
remember the first time we figured out
that anyone was listening it was back
when we were with red band so this is
like 2010 or left 2011 and we were doing
shows and we put out a thing like hey
tweet this and the first time that we
saw like the next day that it was pages
of people tweeting as obvious actually
people I thought it was like a hundred
people this is this thing yeah you know
I didn't have any idea of it but when
they got to this thing and they're
coming in from different parts of the
world and then we did a thing of hey
mommy thanks jeans we're all goes where
you just say that to like the teller and
then we started getting submissions from
all over the world all the least please
leave it keep in the car he had a squad
car pulling people over it was oh we had
a cop stupid he ordered his whole like
on on the job he'd use all the inside
language to order it now he's in uniform
and like it's just bananas man yes I
like you know what I like is the the
silliness of it like the fact that all
over the world something that's stupid
it's a shared joke yeah you know like
that's what I like stupid
[Laughter]
you've got like hundreds of these men
like hundreds of them yes really nice
yeah that's it strange right yes there's
no podcast things very odd your podcast
by the way like I remember doing I'm on
like I think episode three or five of
your podcast Wow
like somebody sent me the thing once
they had they had like it documented all
the episode numbers and the gear on like
the one of the first five or seven I
remember was on your couch in your
office at home yeah and you kept telling
me to sit forward yeah the house is
weird yeah like couch seems like it's a
good idea but it's a terrible idea but I
wanted to ask you Kuki like I remember
you said that like you like the Opie and
Anthony model of like just talking yeah
but how did you did anyone else have one
where you're like oh people will listen
to this like did you like were you
thinking of someone else's podcast like
how did you know anybody would listen to
one I think Adam Carolla had a podcast
he had it that damn I think he did but
when he had it it was like a radio show
yeah did his like a radio show still
does right yeah yeah well that's that's
actually a downfall now I think really
yeah I think people get they don't want
your commercials are 15 minutes right
it's not necessary you know and I think
I just like Dow Opie and Anthony had
just people come in with no structure
yeah bunch of comics and just hang out
and start talking did you ever imagine
like that your podcasts would be like
where it's at now it's crazy man it is
really crazy knows no where could have
imagined it I would have believed it's
so nuts no it's just Anna's yeah I just
just thought it was fun to do I mean and
like I've been people mention it to me
all that like when I when I'm in an
airport they'll you know they'll mention
they're like it just still happens
they'll even mention the weight low back
I saw the weight loss podcast last week
and like but I forgot one episode got
more than 6 million and the other one
was like close to 7 million so Craig
that's nuts downloads that is no that's
been then then there's YouTube we use on
topic yeah millions on YouTube yeah how
did you even know how did you know I
mean I think I remember we heard Oh
Joe's doing a podcast what is that like
I don't even hear about something well I
started doing it on justin.tv
which was like this online webcasting
thing
way back in the day and what we do is we
do it live from the greenroom and Joey
Diaz really get mad shut that [ __ ]
thing off yeah I have a laptop and we'd
be streaming from a laptop like from the
little webcam so we'd have a little bit
this back before laptops had webcams
built in yeah so we put a little webcam
on top of their money and people with
license you were doing that right for
all this oh yeah yeah yeah that was a
long time ago yeah and then that was
probably like 2003 or some low yeah
that's really long ago yeah and then
when I got back from Colorado I was kind
of bummed out and I had to move back to
California because my wife is pregnant
and you know we couldn't live at
altitude because we were like it in the
Mount I went to that house I was so
happy up there I remember that I went to
there to that house when you were
checking it out
yeah we were doing we were doing comedy
works that's right and we drove up there
and and it's like up this crazy road and
you know like a narrow mountain road and
at the very top it was like it was
beautiful sounds and names well for me
it was a perfect combination like it was
a perfect balance so like these shows
where all these people and the UFC all
these people yeah and up there just
nature and quiet was like wow this is
what I need and you know valance myself
out sure like just to have enough calm
so that all this craziness sort of makes
more sense yeah yeah now so the show the
podcast obviously it's gotten bigger and
bigger we've been talking about do we
all know people that like you were a
well-known guy when I met you for sure
but you've gotten considerably more
famous but you're not a crazy loon yeah
how does that work how does that work
you think I don't know I mean like we
all know people that like can't handle
fame well well I do a lot of really
difficult [ __ ] outside of comedy yeah I
think that's part of it you think well
yeah I think part of it is first of all
I have zero obsession with Fame like if
all my fame went away tomorrow yeah I'd
be totally fine with it as long as I
have health and as long as I can pursue
my interests yeah I'm 100 percent fine
with it yeah I'm not really interested
in saying I'm interested in doing a good
job yeah like I know that when people
come to see me that I have a massive
responsibility and I work hard I'm gonna
stand up and I work hard on my writing
and then have a bad set
it will [ __ ] me up for months yeah you
know and it'll make me like batten down
the hatches and grind harder a guy I
don't take it lightly at all right all
right so that's part of it too but it's
also I do a lot of different stuff like
I do yoga I do jujitsu I do archery I do
a lot of working out I've been running
recently I do difficult [ __ ] and in
doing difficult [ __ ] you get humbled
when you're getting your ass kicked
yeah I run them the mountains near my
house yeah it's so [ __ ] hard man like
every time I do like I know like that
there's people that could do it way
better I know there's people in way
better shape and I know that every time
I do it I get a little bit better so I
just keep pushing on it yeah so I just
concentrate excuse me
I just concentrate on doing difficult
things you thinking of it sorry good no
I was gonna say that that's probably a
way or way healthy thing of doing so
basically you're saying that I'm not
focused on my ego and making me a bigger
star more famous more famous that's
usually what people do right like I got
to grow this thing your focus is
external which i think is better as a
human being yeah I think it's definitely
better yeah I think I don't want I have
zero focus on being more famous zero
right I pass on everything as far as
like doing talk shows again magazine
articles or interviews I pass on
everything ever seen
yeah so do you think maybe that these
people who don't handle it well it's
that their whole focus becomes just that
like maybe we hear about him too much
like Amy Schumer's a perfect example you
hear about her way too much like there's
this big Google story I pulled up my
google there's a story about her
breaking up with her boyfriend
there was a story how well did she broke
up with her boyfriend when why the [ __ ]
is at a store guys everything's a story
because she's probably got a publicist
yeah the publicist wants to make sure
you get your name out there all the time
get so people get [ __ ] sick in here
and all you get is so if people want
answer people sick of hearing me too
but if you don't want to hear me yeah
you don't yeah it's easy to not hear me
like you got to go looking for me to
hear me I think the more you put
yourself out there especially today with
you know it's this is we're not talking
about the 1990s like
with social media it's so easy to get
the word out for all the different
things that you want to do that there's
no need to do all that other stuff yeah
and if you start doing all that other
stuff mean you can gain a few new fans
but you also get annoying yeah you know
we all know we all know people that are
just overexposed yeah and only taught me
not Daniel Tosh I was about to bring him
up I was about to bring it last yeah and
he has that thing he doesn't do top
shows he's the best we talked about it
yeah at The Improv and he made total
sense with me and it really really like
cranked home you know real like wow yeah
he's like yeah ideals I don't do
anything
sorry good no he's just like usually I'm
already famous enough right yeah and he
goes because I'm doing an hour a week on
a television show tonight they're like
they get to see me like sound TV so I
don't need to do more yeah than that
like there's millions of viewers
watching this thing and also I guess
thinking being those who like me are
already engaged with me what am i
annoying the rest of the world yeah
you're not into it
well my podcast built up 100% from
someone telling other people 100 percent
I didn't do anything to promote it I've
never done anything I've never done
that's bananas yeah I had one big bump
on Rolling Stone did a story on me and
that was one of the most uncomfortable
weeks that guy following me around and
hang and I'm like staring at me and
writing things down like oh yeah like
weird but that did give a bump though
yeah it was a bump for sure that gave me
a bump but all the other bumps are just
it just it was a gradual slow yeah sort
of escalation until about maybe two
years ago and then it just started
really ramping up like ridiculous like
yeah many millions more per month every
month millions more as you started
getting scary we always referred to like
I'll talk to other people about it too
about your model of I feel like it's
definitely one of like your ideas just
hit them with content in other words
yeah just put stuff out there all the
time because that's like every week I
mean I'll just be on Instagram and I'll
see you're like just yet a physicist on
and you have a comedian on then you have
a [ __ ] hunter on and you're just like
well I'm just putting stuff out there
and then whatever you want consume it
but it's also honestly it's selfish
because these are all just people that I
want to talk to yeah so I'll give a
lawrence krauss in the studio
a theoretical physicist I have questions
I want to ask him about the you know the
birth of the universe yeah but what he
thinks the boundaries of infinity are
and all these different in fascinating
people so I have these one-on-one
conversations with no interruptions for
three hours yeah with someone who you
never get a chance to do that in real
life as if you were at a dinner table
with them they would get up to go to the
bathroom they check their phone people
would chime in someone else would come
up with your own conversation just you
and them alone in a room just staring at
each other and you get you get an
education through that like I've gotta
become a much better conversationalist I
think I understand people better I get I
understand motives better I understand
interaction better
I understand ego I understand I all
kinds of weird stuff you pick up it's
like data chunking you know you just
sort of recognize patterns and people
yeah applying them I just have a much
better understanding of myself and of
people and of being a good
conversationalist yeah you've got you're
definitely highly skilled at it now I
mean not that you weren't before but I
mean I think it's obvious like that's a
skill you develop because you work on it
all the time what's crazy because I
never thought it was a skill yeah I
never before I started doing podcasts I
would never thought being a
conversationalist is a skill yeah I
would've thought yeah you just talk to
people you know I noticed it more like
as somebody that does podcasts a lot
when I watch especially if I watch a
television interview I can tell or I
listen in the bug on the radio I can
hear that oh this host is a giver like a
gracious host letting his subject you
know say what he has to say and I can
also feel like oh the host is trying to
dominate yeah check up on it and like
you're like oh this he's making it about
himself all the time that is an issue
with people yeah like sometimes someone
will interrupt a really good story and
take a sidetrack where they talk about
them settling have an opportunity to
talk about themselves but you're in the
middle of a story
O'Brien you've done this yeah yeah and
then it just becomes a real problem yeah
yes a lack of awareness and a clumsiness
can really sabotage and throw a monkey
wrench into the gears of a conversation
yeah and it makes it real awkward
because the other person is aware of it
and they're trying to be gracious and
get through it and
and you know it's just when someone else
is talking when two people are having a
conversation and someone else is just
kind of like clunky like it affects the
way you're able to communicate so like
as a host of a podcast we're having a
conversation with someone part of the
skill of it is like trying to figure out
how to get that person the most
comfortable and the most relaxed and
then the most like asked the questions
with enough economy of words to get them
to express themselves the cleanest right
that's why I don't like participating in
or listening to podcasts with too many
mic yeah I like on them they get robbers
yeah they get rise it's too much and and
and usually what happens is at least for
me as a listener of one of them I'll be
like every interesting point that I was
looking for like I can hear coming gets
derailed young like taking them like
well gives me anxiety even watching CNN
sometimes oh yeah but and there's like
six people on there yeah oh my gosh when
I hear one one person do I always are
all this we've been given too much maybe
Anna does like nine sometimes yes too
many action they're all so they're all
just like trying to get their sound
bites in you know obviously I was
watching something on Trump the other
day it was just [ __ ] gross what do
you think of what this whole current
state of things are from it's what
happens when you get a guy who does not
understand what being president is and
is used to running businesses yeah and
then all of a sudden you let him run the
president's and he's trying to run it
like a business yeah it was firing
people that he doesn't agree with like
yeah I didn't know that the president
could just fire the FBI chief like that
yeah I didn't know it either but like
when he fired call me and yes like the
guys are he's a real pain in my ass and
just investigation like that what I get
so obviously obstruction of justice like
he has like obvious really wide-ranging
liberties when it comes to hiring and
firing as president yeah and I did know
about that I doubt until this happened
yeah well because most people have the
good sense not to do things like that
because it looks bad as well see
suspicious people forget though the
clinton did the same thing clinton fired
the head of the FBI as well
he fired him in the middle of an
investigation I forget what the
investigation was I forget what the
circumstances were but it wasn't as
egregious but it was pretty similar
because it feels like I mean at least
from the outside it does feel like you
know every day physically this is
heating up into some like major scandal
who knows
because evidence-wise I know it's always
pointed out that we don't have any you
know smoking gun yet but it does feel
like it's cooking up into something you
know I don't know I think everybody
wants it to then that has that sense to
well it's either here's a question like
what's inappropriate and what's illegal
and I think a lot of it's been
inappropriate but how much of it is
illegal through like Sam Harris of the
podcast where he had these uh political
experts on talking about what Trump did
when he had those Russians over the
White House and he gave them top-secret
classified information about Isis
wanting to his laptops to blow planes up
yeah and he's like hey you know when you
do that you've compromised all these
people that were embedded in Isis yeah
that we're telling the government about
this plan that they have sure now they
have to get these people out and hope
these people don't get assassinated like
you can't like in thinking and him
thinking that he's sharing information
like you know what you're not secret
yeah because what you're doing is you're
exposing sources and it's and you know
it's obvious to that like he's the type
of guy that loves having that share a
secret moment I'm sure you're like yeah
I say some well that's the whole thing
with Comey like you know like you wanted
to hug them yeah you want to say look I
hope you can let this go yeah he's like
telling someone to let go a criminal
investigation crate mainship being
compromised by Russia yeah and
apparently were warned that that Flynn
guy was he was compromised by Russia
before he even got an Ave they were they
were he was one book by the Obama
administration and then when when Yates
came over the the Deputy Attorney
General and warned a Trump's lawyer
about it they still didn't act for
another week or two she was a gangster
those [ __ ] hearing yes she was she
was so good she because she did they
were trying to chip away at her yeah and
she was like look what I'm going up yeah
yeah schooling them on the Constitution
schooling them on law schooling them on
ethics and about her responsibility to
the American people like no I'm not
going to institute a travel ban on
Muslims yeah your [ __ ] mind yeah I
think that do yes this is a country of
immigrants you wanted me to do a travel
ban so saying yeah you know ideas like
he's like a murderer and you know and
they all get caught because they brag
about [ __ ] like he couldn't help himself
talking about Isis probably like I got
something good I gotta share yeah brag
about the [ __ ] I love now all the warts
about how they go it's really difficult
because of his short attention span and
he has a tendency to be easily
distracted by visual aids
well good you if you talk about
something you have to show pictures to
him I'm like he wake up and winds down
with cable news and he brags that I
don't read he's like don't like reading
not a rest you know another thing
Solaris you want to talk about the shows
that he watches they're number one
because everyone knows I'm watching all
right him saying that everyone knows
that he's watching these fox news shows
I'm fine
it's it's hilarious that he believes
that that's why they're number one but
we've never had a president like imagine
if Obama did that Obama said well the
reason why this shows number one is
because I watch it but yeah everyone
knows that I'm amazing yeah hey what
everyone loves Obama yeah he loves Obama
yeah I love him always the third uh yeah
just talking about Kanye Kanye loves
Trump he loves Trump yeah you know
everyone was come but the fact that he
talks about himself like he's [ __ ]
Roy Jones jr. like yeah Jones is in his
prime yeah and Roy Jones didn't mean he
was the baddest [ __ ] on the
planet he was talking about it in his
prime it was a way to establish that he
was it mean it's a psychological thing
yeah he's like when Roy Jones jr. gets
out there Roy Jones jr. gonna take care
of business
yes and it was like okay yeah it would
be like a separate power almost like I'm
talking about this other aspect of
myself yeah he was talking about like
this this superhuman force yeah that was
Roy Jones do you mind when Tom gets on
stage ah got the Joe rocks the house
town girl box the [ __ ] house
how many presidents in the past were
this psychotic but because of Twitter
maybe but maybe it's because of things
like Twitter that we now see inside I
mean what if Nixon was just batshit
crazy too but because the limited act
you're seeing that Nixon tapes that's
great what they play the actual T now I
it's really great but he had a drunken
moment with a it's a famous drunken
moment with a reporter where he was
talking about how he has the power to
just go into a room and make the
decision to kill six million people with
a nuclear bomb and that you know that
that hangs over them yeah apparently he
was intoxicated when he was talking
about this this this nuclear option
power that's another very terrifying
thing president and Crenna the president
really does have legitimate power to to
wipe out to wipe out to use nukes I mean
he has a lot more power than we thought
they did because there's so much
restraint ya showed by Clinton even by
Bush believe it or not yeah it was just
even criticized the Trump administration
which is crazy
yeah yes I mean bushing like a [ __ ]
like a like a liberal Daisy right
comparison so reasonable I'm Stein
compared you well the Supreme Court when
the Supreme Court ruled against uh one
of trumps things and Trump's like I'll
see in court you know whereas they dude
that was court yeah because I was hey
that was the best a pre-course yeah but
like Bush they showed this clip of Bush
losing a similar ruling to the Supreme
Supreme Court yeah and his reaction to
it was so reasonable yeah it was like
well we have to respect the court in the
courts decision and this is just the way
it is and yeah although I'm disappointed
I understand that they're doing their
best in light a big part of it I do
think you're right though is the lack of
Twitter restraint because nobody would
ever act like that I know they had sort
later there was an article that said
they had an intervention last week and
yeah they're like you're making it
harder for yourself and then they were
like and they showed him with visual
aids like when you tweeted this and then
this was the pushback and things for the
articles written afterwards like you
gotta [ __ ] stop no it's hilarious it
is I who knows it's good in that we need
to know that this is a stupid [ __ ]
position that no one should really have
right no one should really have the
ability to just be the top
imp over 300 plus million people it's
crazy to give anybody that power there's
no reason to unless he raised a
philosopher king yeah
even philosopher king is subject to that
if he has an ego and if he's a human
being he is the same possibility of
going out of their [ __ ] minds just
it's just too much but why risk it it's
just there should be way more checks and
balances in place yeah we have to be
nutty to even want to be President
of course sir it's an absurd job they're
all they're all megalomania yeah that
way sleep at night who knows could be
next maybe Glen moon hi Glen moon
officially announced my candidacy Armed
Forces commander-in-chief office
president United States of America if
elected I will serve holy will of God
and name Jesus Christ and power holy
spirit from God in name Jesus Christ
bulk moon USA president 2012 November oh
he didn't make it honey baby but I don't
think they come back name female person
self-described 18 year old former
student Franklin or Churchill high
school I met earlier this year 2011
library Livonia if anyone knows hey me
who my last sigh entering her friend's
house on Six Mile Road service drive
west to farm to road after I drove her
there and my motor vehicle from library
I would appreciate you giving her my
facebook address URL I could use some
help securing 18 to 20 year old vote Wow
yeah well he's doing the sign across
right yeah that helps yes in residence
there someone what do you do it does
shoot them in the head or let them live
I think got to let them live until they
until they show up at the end rested
yeah we have to keep them in a
containment tubes though that's a
problem Regan let them loose and we need
to really get real and in a little bit
need to be a park yeah would have Regan
to be lowered the far right ud
institutionalized the mentally ill so we
unleash them on the street and it crazy
because he's a guy got shot by a
mentally ill pretty yeah right out now
yeah how in these out now he has a like
some type of super but he's out but he
has like supervised he has to go
I think to it's his mother's house or
something and but he's yeah he's not in
a prison yeah so weird how old is he
though he's probably in the 60s
yeah I can still kill yeah oh yeah for
sure yeah
hmm it's a it's a bad job and it's not
it's not a smart job it was a job that
made sense back when we were dealing
with Kings and we said well let's have
an elected representative instead of a
king so it was a superior alternative
then we had all these checks and
balances like representative government
having senators and congressmen and all
these different people they were there
to make decisions for the individual
states and the individual individual
states could have their own laws and
regulations and it was it was a fairly
good system for the time but when you
deal with electronic media and our
ability to gather information
instantaneously like yeah and
communicate information like there's no
reason why we shouldn't be able to vote
online no no none we should all be able
to vote online I think their education
should be super easy the very least uh
you know all these I didn't know but all
these all these European countries do
weekend voting for national elections
and it ups their turnouts by like yeah
playing for sale yeah that's a great
idea as well there's a lot of debate or
a election yeah they don't want that
right they literally don't want anymore
participation because first of all one
of the things you're seeing with Trump
that's really disturbing is you're
seeing the rise of the [ __ ] class
yeah like there are a lot of [ __ ]
out there that we're never represented
and they don't necessarily agree with
his politics but they have like an
identity thing now it's it's more like
they're in a group of like-minded people
yeah and it is even it's like a
political party it's like a cult
it's a douchebag cult yeah I know you're
talking about see them on TV all its
legit like there's a lot of people that
are enjoying this because the they're on
a team yeah and it's like whether
they're rooting for the [ __ ] dolphins
or they're rooting for Trump it's it's
kind of the same thing they identify
with a clan write this clan of people
are Trump supporters right-wingers
whatever they're doing but it's a David
just happen to be Trump supporters and
be hangers they could be anything else
it's just people love to be in a support
group of like - yeah but it agree to a
certain thing I don't think they also
like I noticed they're in the campaigns
it was it seemed like it was a lot more
just [ __ ] the other team yeah kind of
thing it wasn't like
about like he makes sense on these
points and that was just like [ __ ] you
guys imagine if Hillary got in the
office and was doing all the same things
that Trump has done as far as like
giving away classified information to
Russia compromising sources and firing
the head of the FBI because he was
investigating her to lock her up lock
her up lock her up all that was like a
big chant during the campaign remember
yeah yeah well he's done [ __ ]
way worse yeah why worse or more and why
worse or yes he's got my worst brother
from cliff now the Japanese gypsies yeah
they're like there's total white trash
people and she's just fighting with some
other woman she's like okay she just got
why works her you know you know what
else is interesting that I was listening
to the Sam Harris podcast we were
talking about how Lang down the river
good Garry's amazing the real the real
interesting issue is the ebb and flow of
support and that if the pro Trump media
unitedly turned on him because there was
some speculations they were upset the
Trump was doing some things some
intervention things in foreign countries
and mingling meddling and other Affairs
that they didn't want they wanted more
of a separatist sort of like the United
States can take care of itself and [ __ ]
all those other countries but when we
started bombing Syria we dropped a mole
a bomb and all this different stuff
there's a lot of people that express
some like there's some discontent well
yeah this is not what we want it's all
we sign up frankly yeah if it turns and
they United as a united front turn on
Trump the very people that support them
which by the way could absolutely happen
here you're when you're a guy who like
mobilizes those armies those armies of
[ __ ] there's they're subject to turn
you especially if you're clearly an
[ __ ] yourself sure if he does enough
[ __ ] ish things and then one day they
just decide to turn on him they were
talking about this like this could be
catastrophic sheriff or his campaign it
like it literally could the very people
that put him in office this same group
if they have someone who represents them
better where it's a Ron Paul or so
one else someone who they can get with
philosophically but they don't think
like for whatever reason they just
decide they don't like them in yeah
which can easily happen totally well it
can happen too because I don't think
Trump really believes all the crap that
he was saying that he was behind like do
you really think he's anti-abortion like
how many abortions does that
[ __ ] probably paid for himself
you know I mean like he's not about all
the stuff that do you really believe I
think he I think you know I I know what
he's a he's a great user given credit
for being the the super talented
self-promoter
many people know galvanizing not knowing
things in the moment yeah I don't think
he blew even I know that he's definitely
lost at least a segment of people this
past week with having his first foreign
trip to Saudi Arabia there's a lot of
people that were talking about like very
very hardcore you know far right people
that were upset that like what are you
doing going there and your first foreign
trip you should be having them pay us
back for 9/11 you should you know why
are you basically mingling with them
negotiating an arms deal I mean it's
just there's going to be things that pop
up every week that people will you know
get upset about have you seen a picture
of Trump and that Saudi Arabian guy and
some other dude holding on to that
glowing yeah so create is that going bad
on that what is that I was a global is a
long blub yeah and it's like showing
it's funny too because he was like the
anti-globalist campaign guy and like
America first nationalism and now it's
like it's a global but it's all about
the world is it with these people once
they get into office even Obama once he
got into office I became kind of a
different person wait I think well
especially like when you're in that
first turn you know you I think
everything just shifts to like I got I
gotta get that second term that's all
they care about I mean he that's it I
think that's a big part of it because
they especially like the one thing I
will say I think I knows with Trump is I
think at the end of the day I don't
think he cares about anything other than
winning winning the campaign winning
votes winning for him easy I think he's
a highly highly highly competitive guy
and to him it's just like everything is
about it's a victory whether it's this
executive order sign this is like a
victory you know the the the health care
thing went down
that was considered a loss I think that
probably was suit like destructive to
his whole psyche and I think all he
wants is to win again have another shot
at the presidency again only because it
means he won not because he really cares
about being president I think he just
wants to win them yeah it could be yeah
I'm enjoying the campaign like the sorry
the coverage of Melania hating him like
they're saying stuff like he tries to
hold her hand and she swats it away and
[ __ ] like that and yeah I think you know
there's a lot like I read they reach
obviously for anything right like if
your presence the thing is like the
level of scrutiny on everything it's
like they were holding hands and then
they let go and they're like she swatted
it anyway baby no they went there is a
great animated gif though where he looks
over at her that smiling then he turns
away she would yeah she's like that's at
the inauguration yeah that's amazing
it's weird it is weird
oh my god rito nearly - it's like you
can say a lot of these things are ours
but that seems so much to see like well
that seems legit and also the fact that
she doesn't live there yeah well [ __ ]
would you want to she just you know she
that's not what she signed up for you
know it was she's running for she signed
up for some BJ's and some scrilla yeah
you know saying some Fendi bag that's
what excited
that's right drinking your teaspoon a
day and then how much dick can you start
right can you think about it's a great
gig and he's probably only horny a
couple days a week old
yeah 75 or some point times yeah you
only probably get it up a few day even
with Viagra yeah we only wants [ __ ] a
few days a week yeah and then the rest
of days a week she's driving
rolls-royce's shopping or new york yeah
night romp
so he's right here right and like so
he's going to turn back smile big smile
right yeah but you forget she's my tribe
this is actually the coldness of the
Eastern Bloc er as well like my
stepmother had a little of that a little
Ally yeah so do you think
also like part of the reason why she
accepted this position life in the first
place it's like there's like a like a
pragmatism
like a cold pragmatism like this is a
good move
of course well she was a hot chick right
she's like I'm good
so that's what you got to do it's you
know you can't model forever pictures of
her and lesbian sort of photoshoot type
things
another's nude modeling yeah since you
did some nude modeling home good looking
lady yeah nudie pics of our first lady
that's crazy that's crazy I crazy if
there was like butthole pics actually
like to spread them shout out was like a
string of spit yeah a figure and we're
back to your mind I got serious Herman
but we got back to the important stuff
quick oh yeah we're living into one of
the weirdest times ever in human history
is yeah because it's totally uncharted
territory
yeah it was that Glasson just classroom
dude that's become in the hunting
community
yeah it's become a giant punch line it
is all over I guess ain't you that meat
eater neither yeah they said we're going
to beat you guys to the punch line and
they said it glass yeah today it's a
beautiful photo there look overlooking
yeah incredible landscape and everybody
just say just glass and know that like
when that data fine you know we have all
these like little inside jokes that one
went like Bonanza crazy haywire it went
haywire yeah people brought binoculars
for my shows in the arc look at the
weather
this is war this is what we came up here
big super long there's been huge red oak
that's a big amount tall metal we could
sweep it around here just glassing just
classic classic but also I have it all
myself I change meadows and this also
opened up a whole new world for us which
was the excitement of a dad boner like
when a dad is really excited about dad
enthusiasm or any other kind they didn't
travel enthusiast
that nobody would get that excited about
except for that well you know
he's a very famous bow rat I cleared
that out before emailing us like that's
not good friend I did not tell you I
told you to uh member he's I watch him
on TV oh yeah you just watch his show
yeah and he said he glasses the whole
look has killed everything in the world
with a comp I read I read about him out
yeah he's like killed the animal kingdom
yeah he's killed Noah's Ark with yeah
turbo a recurve bow is like a
traditional old-school bow it's like
legit through this oh yeah he's one of
the best bow hunters in the world was
recognized yeah so did he know about
this I don't know I know we email yeah
we reach out very sound guys how upset
and all these people are all swearing
yeah are we super nice remember that
yeah yeah he had that one he had a video
where he goes in he spanks a little cub
bear that there was a little bear eating
out of like a dumpster by his house and
he ran up and spanked it and then I've
got oxides about exactly yeah he's like
way out in the wilderness out oh yeah
those I believe it lives in Colorado I
think that's it yeah glass we have
ultimate on there so we we started to
look for dads that get excited about
things you know like that we consider
him in that category and like so like
there's you know what farmers are
no-foam ours are people to get like not
getting really into trains and they like
will wait at train stations for trains
to drive by and they [ __ ] get really
excited I'm calm oh yeah York once again
on the SMC yeah so I'm trying coming
here in stop out North Creek they get
really into it in
wow that's cool well that sounds what
what oh my gosh oh my god it sounds like
an elk oh oh
19:43 Wow Wow
oh man yeah okay
sorry Kennecott away Wow so these guys
just will wait for trains like hours
Tomer train yeah I'm so excited about
that train right I'm excited no you kind
of envy this guy's ability to get super
stoked on something so dumb no that guy
needs to find [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] still your dinner we just abandon
all those numbers in Kiev four five six
two nine here's the air so earth is that
a lot or dad but certainly benign look
at this oh my god it's come in the moon
shadow is coming it is coming over
watching front plane yeah my god here
comes look at this I never seen it like
this
no flashes oh my god here we go look at
it oh my god whoa look at that oh my god
there we go oh my god it's coming right
over as I cast on look at that oh my god
we're getting close getting close
it'll fill the job I got around about is
time guys be very big diamond rings look
at that
come on that totality oh my God look
aside I mean it's cool that makes sense
yes look at that
I knew that census parameters all look
it down there that's better
it is BBS prereq all that's a flower
look at that flag look at that oh my god
but he does telling you how come your
pants also why don't we took that flight
specifically to see that possum you're
right that guy seemed so into it with so
much knowledge Kant doesn't seem like a
casual trip I think by far the craziest
one that we found we've been sent a lot
of these things is this [ __ ] guy I'm
getting excited about something so
goddamn mundane demands Canada Highway
yeah god I love this one I finally found
the last section hey okay okay
well we are in beautiful 728 this is in
fact the I mean this is a highway belt
and running on the highway this is a
downhill section fortunately oh right
yeah I like it it makes me happy every
time I make you happy because I lack
that enthusiasm for the road like this
guys found a way to get pumped on
something so benign see my money rain
decided about I get excited about a lot
of [ __ ] but this did with this guy I see
that and I go okay I want to talk to
that guy about normal life that has got
to come up normal conversation where he
falls apart yeah this is a normal [ __ ]
we talked to this guy about and he's got
some weird disconnecting well I don't
like to talk about bathrooms right right
and this is where he sublimating all
that weird
he's finding a client he's bottlenecking
somewhere he is and you're right about
the lack of sexual intercourse there's
no way this guy's gay or anything dad I
know but that's why our dads because
they show their dads like I might be a
loner well yeah I think we're labeling
dad yeah you calling them dads - they're
older guys yes
I'm assuming that they're they've shut
it down or their wives have shut it down
life has a very short haircut and she's
wearing culottes and sandals you know
what I mean like they're just gonna shut
down yeah it's sad ladies and gentlemen
your trans-canada highway this is yours
Canada it would be something I want you
to Alerus have you heard Wow and you see
this video dedicated all the men the
women who made this great possible it
great highway possible thank you and all
caps nation points it's just whoa those
noises that were like gangbang yeah I
mean that's for a highway being
completed I almost feel like he's seen
every stretch of it right like that's
the thing this is like the completion of
ten years of traveling this [ __ ]
highway and documenting me I do we like
to think of the backstory yeah would you
care for the construction was the part
of it somehow I had a guy on my podcast
Chris Cage who's walked to Appalachian
Trail to know the Appalachian Trail is
yeah it's all through Carolinas right
yeah they start in Georgia and it goes
all the way to Maine he walked it it's
like six months of walking whoa yeah
yeah and this was like a dream like his
dradis I don't know he had it in his
head that he wanted to do it how did he
eat did he bring how does it work bring
food you buy food along the way now you
bring some food oh my only concern now
you say you get excited you saying I
don't get it and I have an email from a
listener I thought would be a nice time
okay your mommy Tina I completely
understand your need for time to have
enthusiasm as my fiancee is just as
chill and unexcited as Tom there is
nothing more agitating than being a
itíd for something and only getting a
smile from my man that just proves that
you are the personality champ
personality is all about getting excited
having different moods and responding
accordingly to other people clearly Tom
doesn't have what it takes to be
considered a champ it's all you
two PS I also get farted on and treating
like treated like a sister
we are definitely into weird territory I
feel like this only happens with couples
who are on the same playing field lots
of love Hannah thank you fans huge
mistake giving out your email address
this one so yeah but they're gonna get
more from Hannah now dad's gonna start
crying for sure I caught him farting on
my sister things getting weird I can't
believe you think I don't get excited
that and you tell them I mean we
discover that Tom gets excited about
football
but I mean the seldom is there a big I
mean you've known him for years to and
it's exciting when he goes it goes to
shows when he does a great show I do
okay excited how do you express your
enthusiasm for Jerry poor control yeah
yeah you can tell you get pumped yeah
yeah I do
I got a rush what does pump look like
from Tom Joe I like cars like excited by
comes really started I saw I thought one
of his cards and I got I was used to
seeing that he had a video camera I was
like I was glowing at the thing so I
like cars
by car magazines and like that's true
okay that's true yeah yeah all the
Corvette right yeah yeah so cool you do
look good yeah you can sit there you go
you farted this morning horrendously
this morning no other last night we both
we immediately excited about that Tori
change no I was a we made sweet marital
relations and then afterwards we were
you know whatever later on and he goes
you know you're lucky I go why he goes
well I held enough art for you that
whole time yeah and I go wow what a
lucky gal I and I think I should get
credit for that
I feel like great I feel like some guys
will let that go and I was like nope
like don't do that right now
oh yeah I just settled in right now and
I was like nah don't let's go right now
beautiful yeah see he can appreciate it
amazing what you're I get excited yeah
talking about this with you guys but now
would your wife be would she consider it
nice to you that you hope do you hold
them energy yeah I'm trying to try my
best
yeah and if I do accidentally let one go
I'd let everybody know get out of the
way out of the way everybody clear house
yeah yeah I got ladies around your
little girls right so yeah house filled
with girls yeah oh that's right a
gentleman
I got a opposite all dicks all day
before take some balls and fart but in
this name don't you think that you get
material out of that that's probably a
blessing blessing in the skies and I I'm
used to it
I mean I'm more male energy I'm not good
with you know we haven't done this
during the show you need to do this what
Christina my big announcement this means
there's a big announcement coming major
I'm so excited
this is down that's a couple tips being
poured into a bowl that means if there's
a big news coming oh this is sound cue
you know how like morning shows will
have like air horns or whatever we have
chips in the bowl chip in a bowl full
conscious of those potato chips being
ported this so loud it sounds like yeah
I thought it was gambling chips yeah oh
right not never phone I think we know I
don't think there's a distinction made
it's so clinky it is yeah I think
they're the thin Lay's kind that's the
world I see when I serve
yeah yep anyway it's big news I'm
finally shooting my hour special
[Music]
when you shoot it all right here it is
denounce Mike and finally make it June
24th
at the Showbox Theatre in Seattle
tickets are on thousand ranch calm the
link is up it is active so you can get
those tickets now please mommy let's
pack it out so I can have a great taping
there's two shows seven and 9:30
bang bang and the great city of meat
rattle I can't wait to go there with so
many mommies they're gonna be awesome
and I'm and very happy for you thanks I
have Seattle's on the short list of
places I would live outside of LA as yes
same as me every day I get through the
winter I just go to Hawaii a couple of
times just let them get through that
[ __ ] rainy [ __ ] yeah really so
once you get through that I think like
intellectually I think it's one of the
best cities like people they're not
pretentious there but they're smart
there's no showbiz influence yes I think
is one of the things that [ __ ] us up
here yeah is the desire for fame like
it's a there's a total absence of that
up there you see way less fake
yep fake tits fake lips fake ass yes
people only whistle it was like people
it's a really cool City I am I didn't
realize you know sometimes you just see
like one thing in a theater and so you
you don't know if you've been there
before I did the more and I didn't
realize until afterwards when I went to
the lobby that I'd been there with you
because allowing yeah did out to me
I didn't realize we're been here before
in Seattle hi I did it a couple weeks
ago and as we were in there they leave
any was like never been here before and
then we got to lobby I was like I have
been here before
because I remember doing like a meet and
greet with you with us yeah we've done
so many places do I forget or get them
all yeah I'll get they blend in but
Seattle I mean every time I've gone
there
I've had some those fun shows fabric
yeah that's why I chose that city I mean
out you know la is obviously my heart
yeah although well what do you think the
the showbiz element that is the problems
it's the problem this is not just a
showbiz element but the problem you were
talking about without Instagram kids and
the Kardashians they're not necessarily
even showbiz they were like at the
attention in districts the attention
industry yeah it's like there's so much
fake [ __ ] and so much like floss
the nonsense and crazy yeah I mean I
feel like Seattle is bases Microsoft and
Amazon and there's a lot of tech money
there and a lot of really smart people
yeah and it's also super green and I
feel like being next to the ocean and
super green like seeing a lot of green
mountains yet is something about that's
just better for you yes definitely so it
for your brain is a very like kind of
showy town you know that we live in it's
like a very like show off thing I think
one of the funny things is like the idea
like that you think you have money in
this town like people who are trying to
come across that way and then you go to
a town like Seattle we're like those
those 22 people are at billionaires yeah
and then they're not even trying to show
you that yeah there were there were like
a sweater yeah yeah you're like that
Bill Gates dressed like a [ __ ] neck
area yeah are you showing that yeah yes
it's odd right it is what are you doing
with all that money he but he does a lot
of humanitarian tons of it that's
incredible what he's done and he got a
lot of other super wealthy people to
donate their money a lot of them you
know like they do that the pledge
well how about Warren Buffett he's
giving it all that through gates he got
it through gates he's interesting cast
like he's literally when he dies he will
die and leave it all to charity yeah
so that's and he's been giving a lot
some of those guys they've been giving
billions as they're alive even yeah
Warren Buffett also lives in like the
same house that he bought like third
Omaha Nebraska it's a super normal house
yeah he drove the same car for like 20
years I have all that money that I don't
understand its aren't you [ __ ]
flossing he's in a ball in bed but his
level you should definitely be falling
slightly a little bit if he married the
same lady I thank you for tea you got
the wrong yeah she got like 1.5 billion
which to him was like goblet get outta
here
nagging at me yeah take a little one
billion billion dot damn yeah yeah he's
still doing pretty well now Jude or
kitties that's a great city too yeah I
love you dork to the earlier
that's what we call it on a town yeah
that's a place that I would consider
living oh yeah you living in New York
City not in the winter months
yeah it doesn't bother me that much I I
think it's all about one thing is like
in LA after a while even though compared
to most of the country lifestyle you
know cost of living is much higher it's
still significantly different than New
York and like I would only go there if I
could definitely live at least pretty
comfortably you know I mean I got
probably baller
yeah happy hour yeah yeah you know I
struggle in New York yeah my wife once
she's talked about moving there that's
like one place where she said she would
go like if you want to go there I'll go
there really yeah I just I think she
just thinks it's like a big glamour
shopping trip though yes I'll she looks
at it had been yeah well she's right
right I mean like there's an incredible
alcohol I couldn't take the other cold
rough oh my god you know you just dress
warm it's not that difficult
do you believe in like eight spots a
night I know that you yeah maybe but not
I don't like that many spots as much as
I like longer spots right I think longer
spots like too long spot take to one
half our spots over 850 yeah because as
far like developing material I think
it's really important to to stretch out
a little bit because you're creating
like you've composing something you're
putting something together a peak in a
valley and yeah you know Diaz and I had
a conversation about that yesterday he's
like I got to go to more places where I
could work an hour he goes because
sometimes I'm home for like a month I
don't go on the road I know doing how
we're set and I got to go do an hour set
true and I got to piece it all together
like that make sense
I don't like the short spots and
especially if you if you're touring a
lot like I have been and you're doing
that long set every night yeah I I don't
particularly get a thrill out of a
15-minute spot I feel like it feels like
I mean I understand it's a totally
different thing and it becomes like a
different skill set but it doesn't even
feel that rewarding because like the
benefit is like doesn't feel like it
like lines up with what I'm doing okay
you're just getting cooking yeah yeah
you're just getting started and the
light goes on yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
you're saying but to me I treat them as
blocks like I have about four 15-minute
blocks yeah and so I like
I'm doing a set tonight I'll say okay
well I did this block last night tonight
I'll do this palak that's true you know
and then one of the cool things about LA
is that I can do three or four blocks a
night like I'll do one set at The Improv
and I'll do two sets of the comic store
I did three set of the comic store one
set of the improv on two Thursday's ago
and yet like television sets
yeah well no one of one different to the
same and one was the Jeremiah Watkins
flip around yeah I'm doing that next
that's a great show and we've never done
it I was the best people to yell out a
subject and then you start riffing on
the subject it's the better you yell
outlaw huh oh yeah hats yeah yep yep and
you start talking about it and you come
up with material and punchlines you come
up with tag lines you come up with like
you might like have a section of
something that you rant about that
doesn't fit anything and then one day
you have a new bit and then you go all
of them there's that thing that I did on
stage at night network it slides right
into there I'm a big believer in that
it's not that hard you know relatively
speaking to say something like a joke
Comeau something funny it's much more of
a challenge to come up with an
interesting topic or a premise yes you
know so that's well I got that that show
sounds exciting yeah I feel like y'all
being like talk about this topic okay
yeah
premises are giant premises are giant
and a point of view is giant and then
from there I feel like it's like that's
the scaffolding that you'll add jokes to
you'll figure out a way to make it funny
and figure out a way to just do it the
right way and for me one of the things
that I started doing really recently
that really made a big difference is
I'll have a bit even if the bits killing
and I know like this pits going well
just developing well I will
outside of stand-up I'll sit in front of
my computer and just write on that
subject write on it in a completely
different way and like say if I approach
it from one leg say like you're talking
about going on a boat you're approaching
from this way then I'll just approach
from a completely different way and just
say okay well this is already in the can
this one's done alright I've got it so
let me just try
attack on it and I've come up with so
many different punch lines coming out it
from a different angle but forcing
myself to sit in front of the computer
yeah and you know I use that program
right room whoever showed you that
program Black's everything out Black's
everything out and gives you green font
so it's like the matrix font yeah and I
just sit there and I can't access email
I don't get notifications nothing so
when you when you write from a different
angle will you then in your bit do the
chunk that works and then be like or
what if somebody's and then like also
present the other angle or sometimes it
fits in sometimes I just find a way
where that it's in yeah yeah but it's
just it's just creating more tag lines
more tag lines more punch line so you're
you have a new hour though right yeah
yeah yeah how long they didn't take it a
lot X months damn yeah that's awesome
every day on post yeah yes I've seen you
as yeah it's a good lesson I think for a
lot a lot of comics like you it came out
and then you didn't have been chilled at
all on that you just like for work I've
see you I see on posts all the time that
you just like spot spot like working
working working all the time yeah I do
five or six nights a week lately at
least at least four always at least four
really well like I worked last night I
took off tonight I'll wear Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday I got
a hot date with the wife and then I'll
probably work Sunday too and then I'll
go out again next week and you're doing
by the way congrats on this tour because
I saw it's it's big-time [ __ ] man crazy
it's great we do in the theater at
Madison Square Garden yeah yeah call me
it's all sold out that's a remain like
7,000 seats or something some some crazy
Alex was nuts meant Dallas was I just
did Dallas it was the biggest place ever
sold out that was 6,000 seats Wow
it was maniacal that are crazy the
energy that you get how do you like it
because it's a total different thing
from 1,500 or 2,000 Caesar it's
different it's a different thing but the
energy when you get 6,000 people
laughing is amazing yeah it's weird it's
just it's a roar so it's a different
feeling yeah but you know man I just I
really like creating stuff yeah I really
like putting together stand up
you know and I really loved the process
of writing things down and like going
over my notes I loved the process of
creating new material I love the process
of sitting in front of that laptop and
staring at the screen I love the whole
process I love the process of going on a
run and like recording a new idea that I
have in my head and then looking at the
notes that I have on my phone and then
breaking those down on paper and then
sitting in front of a laptop and then
taking these ideas smoking a joint going
onstage with it and riffing with it and
then recording it and listening to the
recording on the way home it's like the
whole process to me is is I it's my
favorite thing to do
it really is other you know yeah I think
it is like the biggest thrill I was
talking to somebody about it that like I
think the biggest thrill still of all
things is coming up with something new
and having it be you know validated and
rewarded you like that's a bigger thrill
than anything yeah really is like I
thought of this thing I said it and this
group of people react and then
abandoning it yeah you have to after you
do a record I feel like somebody yelled
out like do the kim kardashian bit the
Bruce Jenner bit right I'm like do not
even know how to do it anymore I
literally don't know her doing London
Lee in it only comics understand now
there you go I've been doing this other
thing for so long now that I don't
remember the beats of that yeah somebody
tried to get I started to do one and I
was like 30% through it and I don't know
what happens next audience yells out the
next line I was like well there you go
well yes even as I'm ramping up to tape
it in a month like I have to sit down
and really go through my notes and
really remember every little hop to it
and bell and whistle go Gore forget the
cadence I'm you can get away without
doing that but make no mistake about it
the more attention you spend thinking
about that material the better it will
get most definitely yeah and I have to
get full focus like I can't [ __ ] around
with anything like it's a laser until
that date and then you know what I know
it's really kind of weird I know guys
that write on shows and they'll write
sitcom scripts and oh right movie
scripts and then they they have like a
chalkboard they write or a whiteboard
and they're write on the whiteboard will
have no
to put like seeing different scenes but
they don't ever do that about their own
act right and and then their their their
own act they treat like you know like a
redheaded stepchild and never really
they never really have that kind of
professional focus because you don't
have to because no one's telling you to
write when it comes to like writing a
show or writing a movie deed you have to
you have to write that because
everyone's going over bit by bit you
have writers meetings you go to the
writers room and sit down people
there's no writers room or writers
meetings for stand-up but why isn't
there like why why don't we because
we're [ __ ] lazy its discipline its
self-defense and also it's hard to look
at yourself and look and step back and
separate you from your work and don't
have that kind of suck like that can be
better I should notice there you know
what I love the most is knowing that I'm
about to say some crazy [ __ ] like when
you're like you take the risk and then
you're hired you're like oh so scary
this could be really I shouldn't say
that
yeah you get addicted to that feeling
yeah I like that like I'm gonna take a
leap right here yeah this is scary yeah
hopefully they'll come with me because
it's not just talking about airplanes
and cats and dogs you know say some
crazy [ __ ] yeah and they and then that's
fine there's there is that risk risk is
what the is that feeling of like yeah
this parachute okay and then like it's
you don't think about it at the time but
the knowing that a bunch of people are
getting babysitters they're spending
their money they're coming out to see
you and there's this massive
responsibility to incite a reaction in
them yeah with just your words and
thoughts the amount of responsibility
that's on you and that it's pretty
intense I've paid more attention to it
over the last year or so that I have
like ever in my life yeah ramped it up
more yeah
I just think it's constantly and then my
standards always get higher too it's
like I need to I can't have a new
special that's not as good as the last
one so I feel like man I got to make
sure this one's better so I have to like
watch my old one and go or what words
they're too much fluff or is it too much
oh you did that really yeah yeah yeah
like maybe I could have cut this down
maybe I should maybe this isn't as good
as this part you know all that just all
sharpening the samurai sword hammering
[ __ ] metal down yeah I know my
problem is I'm a perfectionist so like
and it's never good enough it's never
going to because everybody's problem I
hate it everybody hey if anybody was any
good hates everything they do and true
guys everybody I know that loves their
act is terrible
everybody's ever it tells me all I knew
stuff's amazing I love it like Oh get
away from me it's gross either the Guru
did a show one time with that guy now I
know going back and watching yeah yeah
like I love watching yourself and like
Cheryl was terrible there you go yeah
the case yeah it's weird it's always the
case and they're they're always like big
self-promoters - oh god yes
Letterman hated himself I read some book
about him years ago and every episode he
would go home and just put on the hair
shirt and flog himself like that was the
worst episode ever and in my estimation
he's the best I love him so much but he
hates why he's the best yeah because he
had these high standards he wasn't just
half-assing it yeah yeah yeah it's true
I remember a guy one time asked me to
get him a guest spot in a seg I went to
a city and he was like I knew him I met
him before so I talked to the manager of
the club and I was like can I get this
guy I guess but and she was like are you
bashing for him now yeah so good okay so
he goes up there just eats such a big
bag of [ __ ] so then the club manager is
like what the [ __ ] was that
and I go wow I just I don't know so
there's a second show and I go dude that
was like he was like I know you I'll do
a totally different set on the Sega
start over set and I'll make up for it I
go okay so I go let's just let him he'll
do a totally different set that was not
only does he do the same set he does a
baby
oh I'm opening and so she's looking at
me like me what's going on and I'm like
and I see him I go you did the same
exact thing and he was like yeah like a
black outside nerd I'm nervous and the
other thing that stood out is that he
had this is quite a few years ago like
amazing website and like all my other
stuff had incredible
you know like those yeah yeah yeah only
got the card I remember when you started
doing stand-up and yeah the card body my
hordes I know that sound bear thing like
cards that say your name and likes me as
like as yeah yeah every time I meet a
guy in a town and he wants to do a guess
that I'm almost positive they suck yeah
they're always like real true saying I
really love to guess out a new joke what
Jess said there's six thousand people
yet yeah you're gonna do a guest bet The
Audacity tomorrow
I know yeah I got a show that though
yeah bunch of guys do that I've had I've
also had guys that are like marginal
headliners and you know working comics
just show up let's just show up at my
show and asked to a guest set I'd like
to Chicago theater let's play I'm not
kidding yeah
3700 people hey I like to do a guest
that hey I'd like you to go [ __ ]
yourself yeah hey crazy hell them what
do you say no I go to this is all set up
like this guy's going to do 20
you know he's guy Ian's going to do 20
20 hands closed committed 20 and then
I'm doing an hour in ten like this is
what it is is this the show like there's
no room for your guest set I'll just do
like seven minutes no you're not doing
anything I don't even know what you're
doing yeah I don't know what kind of
wood what if you go up on stage and you
start doing my my subject yeah
oh good get the [ __ ] out I just got an
email about theater he got one for a
theater show lady but here's the thing
would you ever do that never now never
the thing like imagine showing up at a
like there's a if you're a musician is a
band plan I came out I just like to go
home and do a song with yes what if I
got any [ __ ] mind
well the crazy thing about this emails
here because I've had this a few times
is it's an email saying how you're
coming to this city I'd love to do a set
not only do you not know who I am
I will provide no link to anything so
you could check out like in other words
it's just sight unseen you don't know
anything about me
can I be on your show or not and can I
do like 20 minutes
yeah but Ayman no you know I thought
maybe like five I had two guys show up
in Atlanta he want to do a half hour
Alma he said that yeah I said you wanted
right because he does want to do a guess
hat he goes jumped I was only talking
like 30 minutes not like an hour
I remember one time oxen you know Danny
I think that a house although you know I
love Dan Godfrey he used to run the Brea
improv and now he like overseas I think
all the improv yeah and one time I was
in the Brea and I was I think man I want
to say I was knitting this is like
probably like oh six or something and
the but I was I was at I was middling
and the emcee was like I'll do turn to
him with like I'll do 20 and and then
him and then Dan goes he'll do ten he
won't do anymore like this straight up
because the guy was like announcing ah
I'm gonna do from the MCS can out and
wanted yeah he'll I'll do 20 and then
how much do you do he like he'll do ten
and not a second more telling him like
don't even yeah REME about doing that
yeah and people get mad in this
inevitably oh I'll get an angry tweet or
an angry Facebook message and people
will get mad thinking that you know like
you just don't appreciate people that
are trying to make it know what you were
trying man listen I'm telling you all
the people that are out there listening
to have that mindset no one does that
no one who's any good does that this is
not what you do you don't ever ask for
guest spots if you get to know someone
and you start working with someone and
you work with them on a regular basis
and you want to work with them somewhere
you know that's one thing like say if
you know like say if you were going to
be in town doing a wedding or something
like that like you were a friend's
getting married yeah my daddy like dude
you're working that night and I'd be
like yeah you want to do a set you'd
like [ __ ] yeah yeah and then we would
work around it should I figure it out
but it's only because we've worked
together so many times you know each
other so well like to have someone who
you don't even know want to interject
like your your show is like a complete
package like you've put it together
right yeah you know who your opening
acts are you know what kind of material
they do totally and you're thinking
about how this whole thing is going to
play out together and you want to make
sure that that audience who gets that
babysitter and goes on the week you want
to make sure that they get the best set
possible and I'm old school I guess in
the sense that I am 100 percent of the
idea that everything at any show is
absolutely all about the headliners
desires and wants yeah
their show like whenever I open for you
and like somebody would say like hey do
you I agree like I don't know ask him
it's his [ __ ] show like we're all
here it's called support for a reason
like we're supporting the headlining act
and I [ __ ] hate when they try to
involve anybody else in decision-making
or how do you whether I go it's all
about whoever's name is on the market
what ever they dictate is the way that
show goes and you should respect that
you should respect what it took for them
to get to that point and you should
respect their desires at the show so if
you want to talk about lighting or music
or how much time all it's all that
person's decision so everybody else can
go [ __ ] themselves
yeah you know what I also find the album
done I don't I don't do I don't take
guys in the road to do crowd work
I'm like in your life it just opens up
that on-hand Dory's box it's important
real problem where when someone loves to
do crowd work and they start where you
do for a living sir I'm looking at you
with that suit on I'm imagining the
salesman them now
you know the dad the probably thing that
you can't even start boozing and they
wanna I'm going to get my chance he's
going to talk to Mia and then they start
gearing up and then the time never comes
and then you're on stage and they want
to start yelling [ __ ] like oh yeah
changes the expectations of the show yes
and and somebody who's the show is not
about them has made that decision yeah
that's what's [ __ ] up about it
I've had that we're like holy [ __ ] one
guy did a 20-minute crowd works oh wow
really under yeah and did like got in
this a few years ago we got worked into
a frenzy and then you get up there and
some guys like and you're like shut the
[ __ ] up I'm not talking to you man and
then it robble robble yeah yeah it
becomes a problem cause in the audience
mad at you you just get to talk while I
talk I was waiting about my mom yeah
yeah I just wanted to really miss match
my openers like this is back in the day
I was opening Fort Lauderdale and they
gave me this uh this guy who was like
ladies you gotta suck a dick that's why
they call it a [ __ ] not a career some
[ __ ] was like all like ladies you gotta
suck dicks I'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of
here they don't even know who I am
don't give a [ __ ] they're not putting
you care not considering it now no I
mean now that guy would never
about us but being near me but right I
like a guy that the club found funny and
they go I've got an open week from now
yeah yeah from the female comic it
wasn't Fort Lauderdale oh yeah yeah is
there other than Jim Breuer is there a
funny comic that's ever come out of
Florida if he is he had a Florida yeah I
didn't know that
that's right sure yeah Kreischer he's
yeah and I - etosha report is in Florida
- dammit there goes my favorite berries
Todd berry Centauri now Wow but I know
you're saying in terms of like the faint
there's not a moment there that develop
somewhere else there's one other guy -
that's really funny - Kim in Florida um
Brian Regan didn't Brian Regan come out
of Florida you might be right yes he's
from Miami yes sir I got there you go
yeah so my theory sucks yeah no you're
right
but there's no bastion of comedic glory
like for LA reals not what we all go to
get really good well there's no
community right now you know apparently
there was developing one in Miami
because last time I was in Miami was a
couple years ago and I did the you know
they have that South Beach comedy
festival right yeah I went with you
that's right yeah and we were after the
show we were talking to some people it's
one of the local bars in like our local
comics we have like a comedy show here
and a bar here and like we put together
like a real community in my car yeah but
that didn't exist for a while
Miami was the worst improv a history of
not world I had to cancel my week I got
a call like a month before and they're
like look we can't sell tickets for a
white girl
we're gonna have to pull your week and I
was like no problem a month before they
knew they're like the writing's on the
wall know when taken for this white girl
oh yeah my name is big English lady
shows the Joey Diaz used to do half
Spanish shows there Wow would you would
yell out half the punch lines would be
in Spanish and people would fall out of
their [ __ ] chairs crying laughs we
did shows there and they were just it
was Thunderdome it we were hey us it was
cruised I did a set there where I would
weave in and out of Spanish - and while
they write you speak full span and I
would and and it would be crushing it
pandemonium is exactly which
and I did one one time middling and the
headliner did 35 minutes afterwards oh
my god it's like I'm out here and you
almost have to be bilingual yeah yeah
and they're like hearts out and that
give you were to ask that staff like are
you gonna police the room they build
what exact node and everyone was 18
yeah the audience was all and they gave
away tickets it was a whole papered room
they told me a story about how you know
there was that was in Coconut Grove and
there's some there's some bad parts near
that in that area like they were also
tell you like don't walk down the street
from the club oh right and so this was
you know there's like Haitian gang I
forget the name of it anyways dominant
in that area so one time some guy I know
he's being loud or something so they go
to one of the guys is like hey could you
keep it down and then when he comes back
a second time the guy opens his jacket
it shows him he's got a gun
right waistband so the guy's like
[ __ ] from not getting killed over the
goddamn improv you know so he goes tell
the manager the manager knows that the
head honcho of that gang is a big fan of
show it goes to shows there so and he's
in the room so they go tell the gang
leader that like hey this other guy just
flashed a gun to one of my staff and
that guy just turns in the middle of the
show to the guy who showed the gun it
was like hey no and so he got up went
out to his car put his gun in his car
came back was like sorry about this and
they're like alright I'm sorry about
like there's no involving anyone else
and no throwing him out well be a decent
guy put your gun oh Christ
yeah that room was in chaos it was my
offer all right
no I did it I'd I've done the room
before yes go ahead it was one of the
first clubs that I said I would never go
back to I told them on stage oh you were
the dumbest [ __ ] people ever a
performer and they were howling laughing
I go you understand I'm so serious yeah
it worked like a fool clay yeah I'm like
I'm not coming back yeah yeah I remember
Diaz having some choice words about it
to the even Diaz yeah even Diaz like
this to [ __ ] cry
yeah still [ __ ] crazy down there
before Lauderdale was a close second
I'd say Miami was number one and no Fort
Lauderdale Hollywood improv yeah I
always had a good time there
the Seminole yeah yeah that was for me I
mean that's when I was like coming up
whatever yeah I was hard it was I got
the Bluetooth everyone - blue - all
those blue - Toshi's remember those guys
yeah and you're like you talking - I'm
in Oaxaca during your set they were
going for opt
then did me I thank God there's no weird
you know a Ryan Sickler story about that
enough so he had a he needed that tape
for something and so Ryan Sickler is one
of my good friends very funny comic
setup but you know what it's like when
you taping a set for something you want
everything to come together right so he
sets up a camera in the back of the
Hollywood improv and records his own set
and he's up there having a great set
killing leave stage like I got I got my
set to submit to whatever thing he's
sending it in for Tommy said something
so he's just happy he gets back to
review it and a guy sitting next to the
camera the tripod with the camera that's
it like as ryan gets on stage is like
hello huh comedy club comedy i'm at a
comedy club and throughout ryan set you
just hear the guy on his phone call yeah
saying over and over comm comedy club
i'm at a comedy club so that's what Ryan
has a table you know I yelling I'm at
all know you know yeah how's it crazy
Bluetooth man that's budget Cleveland
and right though it didn't hit a trying
I don't see them anymore was almost
other points of it was like a like a
floss that was like she'll like you were
telling people that you had one yes
wasn't about I need to get calls all the
time it was like you see the blink in
there like I'm a businessman ballin yeah
I remember I think the Cleveland Improv
it was just like a sea of Bluetooth ear
pieces oh man I gotta get back by the
way that one was
that was a terrible reason seems to have
made a comeback though Cleveland's do
and I you know damper I've had great
shows in that city that III but that
club clearly improv I definitely had
some [ __ ] really bad crazy shows I
mean there was a guy arrested during the
show who he sent back because it says
one pound chicken wings and he goes that
1/2 pound and they're like that's what
it is man he was like take me to the
kitchen and weh-weh them because I know
that's not a pound oh my god and they
have a by the way this is one of the
clubs that there's a permanent police
officer get stationed in the lobby and
so they're like no he's like I'm not
paying for it so they just get the cop
and they go hey here's the deal and the
cop goes look I thinking like this is
look man you're they're paying for them
I'm take you to jail and the guy just
goes there you go
go ahead so they arrest him Wow over an
order of chicken wings he didn't want to
pay for it Wow all this not a parent
that was good the Cleveland problem you
had merge stolen off your tape I had
merged stolen at the Cleveland who stole
your Mercy's people like they're like we
want a picture and they like totally
distracted me and then when I looked
down I was like doing my own thing then
like you know I have 20 of these there's
like five gone they just set me up for a
picture and I turned back and they were
gone like wow know who the people were
to see them leave did you go after I
mean it's like I turned and I was like
hey I'm telling like the security guy
like they just stole he's like yes so
for me it wasn't like you know
and people steal [ __ ] yeah you're in
Cleveland yeah trying to sell CDs yeah
man yeah I was such a rub the first
night I ever did the Cleveland improv a
John and a pimp I've tried that you know
I'm saying the pimp dancer the hooker
and the John we're getting in a fight
right at the front row and they got
thrown out wait a minute dude took a
hooker to a show yes I found that later
I didn't know at the time and I was just
starting my son here I am my first time
in clean just trying to survive and I
look in there getting assured out I'm
like what happened I was a hooker and
the John they're in a fight that it
doesn't arrest me oh yeah I got people
vomit in my shoulder and they go to my
oh yeah as a Cleveland problem like I
was I was grinding through a rough set
this guy and the third go goes up he
goes so terrible man I got like fully is
loud like it's got terrible hey sup man
and then some lady in the bag goes your
mama should have swallowed that nut like
had meaning like this in Cleveland yeah
the Cleveland proud Wow like damn I go
you - should have stuck around to raise
you and then like I got out of there
pretty quick it was what did she say
when you said that it was just it what
there was so much booming and ahhing and
like and swearing and then she was she
was removed so like she was allowed to
say her thing I said my thing and then
there was like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and then they
actually heard about what happened after
that show calm down or no yeah they let
me it was like as I'm winding into the
closing bit of the set so I was like it
was right before I shut it down anyway
like it was I was about that close and
then yeah I mean I remember I walked
pretty fast off stage though as I got
out of it but that was so much there
were some rough sets in that room yeah
Cleveland's rough yeah so but but
hilarities is pretty [ __ ] different
that's different yeah different yeah
yeah I mean like it's a beautiful room
and like you know I mean improv has
great clubs don't give you wrong that's
like a rougher that's different yeah I
was there recently with Fitzsimmons
Garrity yeah I was there
on Akeem I flew in on Thursday night I
had a show there on Friday and
Fitzsimmons err on Thursday so I did a
set on his show on Thursday he didn't
know great he officer it was great
hilarious
we started out like a week apart from
each other thank you really yeah yeah
literally a week apart I just did his
podcast couple weeks ago he's that
natural like when we talk about the
skill set of conversations yeah he's
really good at what his dad was a big
time radio host yeah I didn't know that
yeah in New York yeah yeah Wow Greg and
I did so many [ __ ] gigs together we
should steal each other's material well
we had a deal because we both neither
one of us were really we really should
have been working you know we were
always like the only years ago more MORE
yeah like 89 88 wait how long you been
doing it since 88 August 27th 1988 shoes
and we're coming up on your anniversary
yeah yeah in 19 in 2018 it will be my
30th anniversary Wow crazy I'm exactly
half that yeah yeah um
and anyway um so Greg and I would like
would do gigs like when were a year in
and we'd get paid you know to go on the
road and so we had like a deal like you
could do my material to your material
that's a good idea I just heard a really
good friend yeah so as I dude you're
[ __ ] material is killing and Mexican
and he's like seriously yeah yeah when I
would tell him ha you know that bit that
you do I did that in [ __ ] Rhode
Island yeah but it was like it was
parachutes for you guys oh yeah yeah we
really shouldn't have been working we
were doing comedy a [ __ ] year and if
something went bad it went bad
yeah you know like I never recovered
never I'm yeah convert you know he could
have a [ __ ] joke and just bounce back
from a totally if something stumbled
through something he can bounce back
from it back then there was no there's
no recovery I remember opening on a bad
joke and just writing that sad way
how long's that yeah you opened that
yeah I didn't have a way to hold it back
together
yeah you come out stumbling yes never
get your balance back yeah now you open
if you open bad you like you know is
there one place where you won't work
where you want where you won't get
booked just like I'm not going there
yes like where is it Cleveland temple
you will do a base negative sign and
land like I had to made a bad audience
right that does happen if you know the
problem is it's same thing that happened
what Miami did with their with their
club is that they used to like announce
that you can get free tickets yeah so
like number one time going there working
and I was like check out this line is
awesome maybe it's going to be great and
the guy goes they're here for the free
tickets so like when you're when you
cultivate that this is free mmm it just
it you know it's a financial value it
does when you just go like though these
are $5 tickets you're making an
investment in your night in the show
yeah and that changes it and I think
Cleveland did a lot of that too a lot of
like this is free the worst thing you
could ever do to a show paper it isn't
the people to start talking okay they
don't give a [ __ ] doesn't mean anything
they'll would get up and leave in the
middle of the show yeah nothing invested
in it for me it's Connecticut I don't go
to game yeah you don't I heard you told
me kinda kid can suck my whole city are
jehovah the holsters are I say no no
disrespect to anybody in Connecticut no
disrespect no disrespect I did it like
Irene times this year yeah yeah yeah all
those people you know you know where you
live I did Yukon I had a great time at
Yukon I did the college a bunch of
people from somewhere else yeah but it's
stuck in your head if I could guarantee
that they'd bust people from New York
and Boston I'd do a show there you would
never do the Foxwoods ha ha ha ha
Fox where are you most excited about to
go on the store I like Texas well I mean
I just I like going places where it's
fun yeah something about Connecticut
that's just bleak yeah there's like a
lack of opportunity this is something
bleak about it it's almost like an
illegitimate state it's like a highway
between Boston New York that's really
what it is and it always feels like that
when you're there just feels weird like
there's a lot like almost like there's a
sadness
it permeates the show you when they
laugh like haha I love that you hate a
play so much and yeah so many bad says
there you know I feel like I had a lot
of places when the cameras are off we
can talk about them oh well Diaz and Ari
and I did a show at Foxwoods a few years
back and and I told them before I go it
was like a Monday and a Tuesday night
because they had a comedy club at
Foxwoods oh yeah compiled a comedy club
and restaurant I had to put that on my
website
I got a comedy club and restaurant they
make you say any restaurant and
restaurant yeah make you make you on the
other hand your promos like could you
[ __ ] say the full name oh my god I
have him there I had a bad set so did I
oh yes anyone that was great that was
the last time and I was like never again
I told you guys before this is probably
gonna suck and and I was like I knew it
was gonna suck but I didn't know was
going to so yeah oh yeah it sucked
yeah it's just it's just the people were
they wouldn't stop heckling they were
yelling out during re-set yelling out
there even Diaz is like we just shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah I want to add someone thrown out of
there and afterwards like some of that
was like so what was going on and
they're like and the other thing is that
here's a bad thing about people don't
realize about casinos is that there's a
losing like this total idea that it
benefits any aspect of the casino to
keep the customer happy regardless of
every other circumstance in other words
somebody is upset at the restaurant well
let's try to make it right because
they're they're here at the casino we
want them to stay happy keep gana to go
to a comedy show well whatever they're
doing is fines like no no no whatever
they're doing is not fun because this is
about the show but the the venue's point
of view is this is a gambler this is
somebody who's here than money oh yeah
we should always acquiesce to their you
know desires and needs and don't don't
do anything to upset them yeah how that
works man like this is this is our show
my favorite with the casino gig it's
always how they you know you've got the
ding ding ding ding ding the Machine
sound oh no
there's a curtain that separates the
comedy club from the ding-ding-ding
Damon you can still hear it like they
actually have a show in Vegas at the
South Point that dirty yeah already yeah
they'd like your you can look out and
you see the casino while you're on stage
in the back of the room there's the bar
I want to find casinos right there
weird can I ask you would you ever date
your mom definitely not first of all
she's all with me and I couldn't ball
she's my mom well why I'm your mom and
you're my son and I am falling in love
with him he says are you really I said
yes I am you think you know what I was
going to let you know too I am too both
consenting adult if if it comes down to
it you know it's just like the gays
there you know as long as they're over
18 everything's fine you know I mean the
US wants to jail them for 18 months
without fix they got arrested they
actually got arrested oh well they
should definitely arrest them what the
[ __ ] do you want to [ __ ] your mom that's
our point I don't care I don't care at
all
I think it said that he wants to marry
his mom they're illegalities [ __ ] yeah
got a tattoo on her face yeah they go
for it
there's that go back to her all right
it's definitely like relaying that it is
just like the gates the same way the
same that there's nothing quite like
marrying your mom
it's very strange though see them making
out ah it's her end yeah will you ever
get your mom in or you date your son I
said I'll shoot the yes I would
19 years you're the best thing that ever
happened to me and I really want to be
with you rest of my life as I go again
don't be bagged up at a tattoo on her
face it's just like the gays are the
best thing ever I ask ask them there's
no K in that scenario mom there's no
doctors that say I ask them where's it
hurt they asked him when the great like
that eat so it's so great it feels like
it but I think it is real because I read
a follow-up article the bus again
arrested and everything yeah so what do
they do they tell them you gotta stop
[ __ ] the guard it I think it I think
the marriage partner Springs looking
that yeah that's true but I also feel
like if you're [ __ ] or like you want
to get married to your mom like you just
stay inside it's that they're doing this
see that's the problem with today's
society is that everybody has to be out
and proud about every stupid [ __ ]
thing they're doing - what happened to a
little sense of shame
keep it inside you know it's [ __ ]
weird yeah you know it's weird yeah it's
like the gays right yeah like what - gay
it's just like I gave it's just like
McCain Odin I like to get out no no no
no gay people they didn't see that's
it's definitely unless you're [ __ ]
your dad it's different yeah well that's
right
well speaking of that do your in first
fantasies haunt you do you feel guilt or
shame around them maybe you've never
allowed yourself to have them because
you think it would you would be a
terrible person if you ever went there
so it's all suppressed she went on to
say that she started to masturbate and
then thought of everyone in her family
and realized the only one that turned
her own was her dad and she thought
about her mom and her son and all you
people and she just didn't do any funny
business dad did and it also made me
think it's just like the gate you know
real quick were you with me when we were
I did I don't know if you were with me
that time when I did I was called Jim it
was open gym and we watched that were
you with me when we watched the footage
of the guy at the carport the guy in the
garage the asian guy oh Jesus which home
wasn't what would you let me see you
sounded you missing this footage
it's a car backing into a garage like in
mechanic shop so I just faced hard place
you just look familiar no not yet I've
seen too much yeah that's true [ __ ]
we'll ask like different not seeing a
lot of laughter on Joe's day your face I
see a lot of laughing Oh gross that dude
check out how could turn his friends are
like so happen oh yeah it looks look at
how [ __ ] cold back I feel down here
Joe's laughter it all it's not really
love hello too many injuries men
injuries to me aren't funny really
whoops keep going with this thread why
aren't injuries funny generally I see
people get [ __ ] up all the time yeah
[Applause]
that guy's got broken legs broken hip
like the impact with that the cement
wall and then the toolbox and then his
leg the legs are the soft thing the legs
are going to give that's kind of funny
though the funny about that evening the
wait a minute wait doesn't half what did
you just say Joe it's not funny to me
yeah me neither because I think we have
empathize our broken legs I do yeah he's
worked this out before no I really don't
know I'm not good with injuries really
yeah I always hear any injury here's my
problem like God
I've always last I think it's because of
my own fear of them probably on some
level I've always had a like I remember
one time I worked construction in
Florida one summer and one of the
formulas like I had a bathtub dropped on
my neck I started laughing so hard like
tears running down my face he had a
bathtub jumping and he had a permanent
more
impacts sewn into his inside Intuos just
drip it on his neck I go ah he just I
just laughed laughs I couldn't stop
laughing so crazy but I mean it's not
even it's not a calculated choice to
laugh it just happens that's why I think
it's because I I actually fear it happen
yeah that but if it's not calculated now
starts happening just I'd have it all
here so yeah I can't control myself I
see so many injury that's true usually
equals head get bashed in they've got to
realize I've probably seen more people
[ __ ] people up like genetically and
fights yeah then maybe almost anybody
who's ever lived that's probably true up
close yeah I have called I mean it's
probably a few guys that are closing in
on me now numbers-wise
other commentators on fights but I've
commentated thousands of fights yeah
think about that all the different
concussions I've seen all the different
knockouts now here's the funny thing is
that I really don't I don't laugh when I
see head trauma no no it doesn't do it
to me like leg trauma yeah ah yeah
screaming the screaming is like it makes
me laugh and it's all of us being
crushed by the car hilarious but as Evo
did show me this new guy that he's
working with steve-o's like mentoring
some young psycho yeah who's doing a lot
of like Jack a style stanza and his kid
put on a speedo and rode a skateboard
off of a makeshift ramp into a pile of
cactuses it was so [ __ ] crazy I was
watches like oh my god like my whole
body you know that thing we get when you
see someone about to get in an accident
and like yeah 10/10 yeah as Rendell in
pumps to your body and like it's almost
like you feel like sharp pointers all
leather skin yeah that's how I felt when
I saw watch this kid launch his body
into the cactus or no we saw when that
we remember that but yeah I don't talk
about it again where this dude was
trying to do a jackass stunts and he had
got a rope around his nutsack and tied
the other end to a tree and then ran and
jumped oh no
rip his balls off yeah he died
but Hitler balled his nut popped out man
it's his video this day yeah don't have
it maybe I want to skip [ __ ] when I came
out well what did you think was going to
happen
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh I can't
even do that even look at that I can't
even look at that
I can't yes you like that doesn't make
me laugh that definitely freaks me out
but do you think that I mean this is
like a cliche thing to say but don't you
think that that in some ways is
evolution like that there are at it out
there's dumb people that will do dumb
things and it's almost they're supposed
to die or lose their ability it's kind
of symbolic to this guy's tying this to
his reproductive organ you're right and
now you're right maybe maybe it's an
unconscious wish fulfillment like he
doesn't want to live to reproduce yes
yeah I mean what do what would be best
case scenario there hey it would hurt
his balls and they wouldn't rip off Yeah
right right he jumped with the rope oh
my god oh my god okay all right all
right don't worry yes oh my god oh my
god oh
for you and the bar and no I mean I
wanted to talk about your morning cards
but that you know I got it I'm mourning
for as opposed to what evening parts
very different well I'm a real I don't
know if you are I wake up with lots of
noises no just all I'm a [ __ ] stall
working or I'm a symphony and you find
that your digestive tract and everything
is working but excuse me working better
since you're dying
100% yes you used to [ __ ] a lot worse
and now it's much better
yes you used to have like diarrhea every
day yeah I think he's allergic to sugar
or
I think everybody is well I have like
even now you know I'll be pretty clean
for a number of days you know even weeks
I'll be like I'm going to eat this right
now I'll indulge in something rich and
sugar if I can never agrees with me Oh
kills you yeah you got used to it for a
while right yeah and now that you're not
used to it your body does know what to
do with it it's what is actually found
that in a lot of what times what I want
is just like a taste of something always
have a bite and I'll be like I'm
actually I used to go like I'll have 70
bites of that and now it's like 1 or 2
kind of satisfied yeah and then I don't
feel sick isn't that Xevious stuff
[ __ ] amazing dude I love it yeah she
needs it the little water guy spit it
out water yeah Martin Arisa spit it out
and and I but my theory on is this
though if somebody who's like
restricting themselves from sweetness
all the time it's like an indulgence you
can have yes so it is like it's I notice
it's a lot it's too sweet for a lot of
people's palate but you don't know how
much sugar there regularly having the
other words for me I feel like it's that
like the free cheat right so you have
your zebra you taste sweetness again
it's not it doesn't bother me even a
little I enjoy the taste I'm not anymore
I feel like it's to synthetic tasting
that's what bothers me it's like I like
a dr. pepper alike taste BIOS I like a
Lacroix I'd rather do that oh those are
great
I love those I think that those are so
light yeah you know they have Z via
water where it's just like at the
tiniest hint of flavor it's more like a
Lacroix ok man so they have the C via
soda they have Z V energy drinks too
which are amazing they're really good
that you know that better tasting than
redbull
oh yeah totally people we get a lot of
song submissions people send in songs
they make do you know like somebody made
let's go water champ that you said into
a song like they do please tell the
audience so I can have already good at
that you're impressed with my water can
somebody who's a lot
you're the water champ keepin the water
champ for as long as I've known you kind
of the water on the water
even the water champ propaganda let's go
for scope let's go water shaft on the
water on the water let's focus so let's
go water champ schedule rip this town
the water a lot of champions
top just it why no way don't pick go
let's go water champ out on the water
out of the water I am right now does
that bother you you guys are better than
me all the time are you guys competitive
with everything just weren't you guys
competitive with stand up now just roids
import your own personality water oh now
that's probably why we transfer it into
like water and personality I never in
late yeah this is a real argument no but
like but I mean I was it was real when
we were arguing initially about who
drinks more water like I thought it was
because I do know I had a doctor tell me
I should stop drinking so much waters
what kind of doctor was he urologist he
goes are you drinking too much drink
drink far less yes remember she's an
exaggerator I am didn't really tell you
to stop drinking warm up he goes how
much you drinking and I told him he goes
you need to do that that's not that's a
myth he goes just drink when you're
thirsty you're over hydrating true story
can you over hydrate though you hand if
you go and I'll eat really nuts yeah if
you go like like a radio contest or when
we when we do water cut for the
weigh-ins I mean I don't know exactly
what I know I didn't feel good but I
drank over a gallon of water like during
that part of the last podcast and didn't
have to pee yet I remember that you kept
throwing down the water we talked about
it you had like nine or ten [ __ ]
bottles value but I mean that's not good
probably my body was like so craving
water yeah but you just wanted to win
that running away Joe that was a
horrible the two or three days leading
up to those lands were just horrible at
our house I mean he was taking hot baths
and then going into the jacuzzi and
drinking distilled water and then going
to Burke Williams and doing the sauna
and then
I thought he was going to die you really
did it though that was what was
impressive about it like you [ __ ]
went for like burnt was kind of
pretending to be going for it which is
really interesting because you were
talking [ __ ] to him I know you're being
comedic but you were also being honest
yeah you're like this was calling
playing catch up suckers yeah yeah you
guys want to buy into that [ __ ] yeah
yeah he was trying to catch up at the
end the boys you had a sustained effort
a disciplined effort over long period
from the jump off I knew that that would
be the two ways psychologically that we
go I know yeah from the very beginning
that yeah you had to deal with his
craziness yes that was the thing about
crazy and I even talked to him about
that and I said the crazy is going to
help you I go but you're going to need
more than the crazy I go because you're
crazy is going to help you but your body
can only lose so much weight over a
short period of time right so don't
think because Tom's not [ __ ] around I
go he's really doing this so like you
can't just rely on crazy
yeah like I know I know I know I know
I'm only drinking devil Cheetos and so
does Christmas exactly so great is his
videos he's always so drunk yeah I worry
about him man because he's like what 46
now or something like that
how old is 43 oh that's not bit off you
know yeah but what's great is okay but
here's the thing say he's 43 you can't
do that when you're 50 I agree now agree
we kind of can but you're you're gonna
fall apart
well you can if you have those Mickey
Mantle genes yeah that long-form DNA
yeah long strand DNA yeah you there
comes a point in time where your body is
like hey man you can't do this every day
I know it's enough he does have an
incredible span among kanima to the
ability you know like it I'm like I
admittedly not a party guy man like if I
have a few drinks and I'm 38 I mean I
feel it for days yeah he has that like a
he's just like what let's go out and
he's like dude like when you sent Lee
very graciously sent us to go watch the
Cavs and warriors play for for doing the
weight loss thing you know I mean we was
like drinking in the morning and I was
like I gotta go take a nap and it's like
did like Howard he's we all go to the
bar see
whoa and I just you know I I took a nap
and like I mean I had to like really
pace myself by the way whatever came out
of that with re re well as I mean people
know now he was gone for a long time
right he finally came back from his
Vision Quest and more months four months
oh it's a good I'm so jealous
I know eighty-five percent of it was to
avoid his debt with you guys yeah yeah
as long as I don't have an email or
answering phone he said that he did a
podcast yeah he opened up as saying it
was because Tom's tastes were so
outrageous though yeah he snacks on
caviar yeah yeah so they're very funny I
was pretty irate about his podcast
coming back with it where it was very
funny and he was actually even joking
around that that was why yeah man he's
like he called me he goes all right
where do you want to go but I go I don't
know he's like I've gotta [ __ ] do
something like it I get like a hundred
tweets a day like hey yeah I told him I
already took care of it I did I told him
I got old there's nowhere I don't want
to go I'm fine but he was like oh thank
you somewhere well he [ __ ] up when it
when it happened at the time yeah
they're supposed to step up then yeah he
was trying to figure it out of it
yeah he was your oh no no 24-105 things
shorter than like right man yeah well
what was his argument the BMI he was
like he's like well BMI wise you're not
actually six feet or 511 and 8/10 so
your actual BMI to get out of that had
to be if you were an inch taller or no
they said 25 pounds rented it was kind
of write it down paper with him I know I
know
I learned my lesson that's another crazy
[ __ ] he say now I'll tell you later
Oh
sanim oh now all right we should we
should we should wrap this up so there's
anything else you have now Jane all
right thank you for coming Joe yeah tell
madam we'll do this we do this run down
at the top of dates but just so you know
you go to Joe Rogan dotnet - tor are you
doing you better hop on it cuz you added
all these shows and those are going to
go quick yeah I have a second shows too
like a lot of places yeah or maybe nuts
yeah here's a song how I glass by young
patreon our way out thanks a lot for
coming man my pleasure thanks right yeah
you found the ranch baby but the puppies
down junkie
put that down yo
just live in this meadow with the
flippin walk just think you've met a
glass now here at day football football
football football I look this damn moves
right on his ass ain't you heard this is
how a glass oh oh I was right
[ __ ] say good night for bad
must ring itself aside and my arrow into
flight I got a really bad fight what is
Celtic six or seven thunders last year
you never see the moose go down and quit
huh
but amerimike and Wilson knew about that
boy well there's dad alright I never had
a massage very honest with my dad some
smell of his peers percent of us has a
fuel of the compass you know that I'm
bear ain't got no simple to plug in my
head it's just like the game will you
marry your dad you gotta be coming those
walls and there's double five Joseph
your mobile Ross fa RT Thomason the
crevice of you twist a bigger pajamas do
you know how much money my smile is I
got a really bad back got a really bad
bite comic - buddy under tonight just
slipping around this meadow - through
the wall to stick use metal glass now
here Eric de football football football
football I'm a foot Denver's right on
his ass ain't you heard this is how
classy dick hang low it in the polls
yeah - to know your uncle water sir
Wow with a very amateur get out are you
feel about this we hit the shot with you
to give you peace
unlike my hair my playing is under you
can shoot mom after the hair my car as
long as glass as well a moose that's got
us all has left us all this glass glass
glass glass glass slide a moose that's
all animals
[Music]